[musique]
Jean-Pierre Petit, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Je vais
essayer de me présenter et surtout je
pense à une chose suivante, c'est
qu'avant de venir à l'émission, j'ai
consulté internet et donc une
intelligence artificielle et on a posé
la question qui est Jean-Pierre Petit ?
Alors à ce moment-là, on a des réponses
comme par exemple Jean-Pierre Peti est
connu pour ses travaux de
magnétohydrodynamique, pour ses travaux
sur son modèle cosmologique Janus, pour
ses bandes dessinées des aventures des
selles, menturel et cetera. Et puis ils
ajoutent mais euh il est contesté pour
certaines positions dans des sujets
comme par exemple les ovenis et c'est
considéré comme non sérieux. Et puis
également il a été contesté par
l'académicien d'amour dans ses travaux.
Alors moi j'ai repris le dialogue avec
l'intelligence artificielle et on voit
la chose suivante c'est que je ne suis
pas contesté. Quand on est contesté,
c'est qu'on peut répondre, c'est qu'il y
a un débat, il y a un dialogue. En fait,
quand on pense à cette contestation,
c'est un article de quelques pages mis
dans un blog de du site de l'Institut
des études de Burivette en 2019 et
personne ne l'a lu et il est impossible
de dialoguer avec ce personnage, il est
impossible de lui répondre. Donc voilà.
Donc je suis quelqu'un, je ne suis pas
quelqu'un de contesté. L'intelligence
artificielle en convenait, je suis
quelqu'un d'ignoré. On m'ignore. Alors
simplement, je voudrais dire que vous
connaissez la phrase de je crois c'est
Chopenware qui disait "Une idée passe
par trois phase. D'abord on s'en moque,
ensuite on l'attaque et ensuite elle
paraît naturelle." Mais non, il y a
quatre phases. Il y a d'abord on s'en
moque, ensuite on attaque et puis il y a
une phase intermédiaire, c'est le mur du
silence. C'est-à-dire qu'actuellement
moi je suis face à un mur de silence.
J'ai même fait une bande dessinée
là-dessus il y a plus de 20 ans et
effectivement quand on ne peut pas
répondre à quelqu'un, quand on peut pas
le contester et bien on fait comme s'il
existait pas. Voilà, je me suis
présenté. Voilà.
Jean-Pierre, on est très content de te
recevoir aujourd'hui. Euh ma communauté,
notre communauté nous a demandé depuis
très longtemps de traiter le sujet OVNI,
de traiter le sujet cosmologie,
astrophysique et le modèle Janus. Donc
ça fait à peu près 2 ans qu'on bosse le
sujet. On a été voir beaucoup de
personnes, des personnes qui tenaient un
manche, des personnes qui tenaient un
stylo pour leur poser des questions. On
a même été posé des questions à des
sous-marin concernant des torpilles à
hypercavitation
euh depuis quand ça existait, depuis
quand ils étaient au courant. Donc
aujourd'hui, on va parler OVNI pan.
Jean-Pierre, première question, est-ce
qu'il faut croire aux OVNI oui ou non ?
Ben disons que j'aimerais surtout que
notre interview ne soit pas centré sur
le sujet. Parce que bon, moi je suis
avant tout scientifique et ce sujet, je
veux pas dire qu'il est périphérique. Je
préfère dans cette histoire-là euh
satisfaire la curiosité des gens qui
regardent cette vidéo. Ils veulent
quelque chose de concret, ils veulent
pas une croyance. Est-ce qu'il faut
croire à ceci, croire à cela ? Je dirais
il y a un point très précis. Disons
qu'en octobre 2025, j'ai publié dans une
grande revue scientifique Journal of
Modern Physics, un article justement qui
présente un objet qui s'appelle les plug
stars. Alors, plug, il faut savoir une
chose, plug c'est la bonde, c'est la
chasse d'eau. Et quand vous allez dans
votre toilette, vous enlevez le
couvercle de la chasse d'eau, vous
cherchez à la faire déborder, ça fout le
corps par le tuyau central. Bon et bien
moi je pense que les trous noirs
n'existent pas. Et à la place, il y a
des plug stars. Et ces plockstar, ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire quand on
prend une étoile, par exemple une étoile
à neutron, et bien quand elle reçoit de
la matière en excès, elle s'en
débarrasse en l'inversant au centre et
c'est diffusé dans l'univers négatif. Et
ça c'est un article très solide et en
plus ça justifie les données
observationnelles des objets super matif
qu'on a pu observer au centre de la
galaxie M87 et de la Voie lactée. Donc
parce que dans ce modèle, le rapport des
longueurs d'onde est de trois piles et
ça correspond à ça. Donc c'est un
article théoriquement solide et
observationnement
justifié. Alors maintenant, quel est le
lien avec le sujet OVNI ? Et bien en 91,
je suis passé dans une émission sur la 5
interviewé par Berkov et je faisais
allusion à une conversation de 1988. Ça
ça remonte pas un paquet d'années. Et
là, il s'agit d'un technicien
électricien qui s'appelle Dominguez qui
à 3h du matin a un appel téléphonique
avec un bonhomme qui prétend venir d'une
autre planète. Et à ce moment-là,
Dominguez lui demande qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un trou noir ? Et l'autre lui
répond ça n'existe pas. Quand une étoile
à neutron est déstabilisée, elle se
débarrasse de la matière en excès en
l'envoyant dans le univers jumeaux. Et
ça c'est pile poil l'article de 2025.
Voilà. Et ça c'est quand même fabuleux.
Alors il y a une chose, c'est
effectivement c'est pluger. Est-ce que
ça existe ? Et bien donc dans ces deux
images
M87 et la Voie lactée, on a ce rapport
des longueurs d'onde qui est tro et vous
savez quand on fait un un modèle
scientifique il y a ce qu'il appelle ce
qu'on appelle être falsifiable.
falsifiable, ça veut dire que on va
prédire quelque chose. Si ça se
confirme, on a raison. Si ça se confirme
pas, c'est douteux. Bon ben moi, je
prédis que toutes les images auront ce
rapport de température de 3. Donc
autrement dit, si le rapport est 3, ça
veut dire que ce modèle est solide et à
ce moment-là, on pourra se poser la
question comment [grognement] se fait-il
qu'un scientifique comme Jean-Pierre
Petit annonce ses travaux scientifiques
35 ans à l'avance puisque je suis passé
chez Berkov et j'ai dit je vais
travailler là-dessus. Il y a il y a et
n'importe qui qui va sur internet trouve
cette séquence. Je parle, j'ai pas la
tête que j'ai maintenant mais voilà
pas loin quand même.
Voilà.
Le temps le temps n'a
[raclement de gorge] pas n ne pas
d'adhérence sur vous sur toi. Ça ça
constitue une réponse quand les gens me
disent "Est-ce que vous croyez si vous
croyez cela ?" Ben je peux vous dire la
chose suivante. Je me pose carrément des
questions. Quel était le personnage que
Dominguez avait au téléphone en 1988 ?
un mec de la CIA qui a essayé de
t'inxiquer,
mais un type de la CIA qui connaît la
cosmologie, qui a de prédire tout ça
parce que dans cette histoire-là, il y
avait euh il y a pas de un seul univers,
il y en a deux. Dans le second univers,
le temps va à l'envers. Il étaitorphe en
miroir. Euh l'an de courbure est moin1.
Enfin, il y a des tas de trucs. Et je
crois que je pourrais résumer ça en
disant [grognement]
tous mes travaux scientifiques sont
inspirés par ces histoires là, quoi.
Donc voilà. [rires] Donc là, je peux
répondre, est-ce que c'est intéressant ?
Oui, sacrément. Voilà.
Donc nous, on a décidé de faire ça parce
que notre communauté nous a motivé pour
s'intéresser s'intéresser au sujet et
spécialement quand la marine américaine
a a publié des vidéos d'un objet de
terre ou pas de terre,
on sait pas d'où ça vient, mais avec des
capacités physiques très supérieures à
la technologie que nous ou que nos
alliés ou nos
ou pas nos alliés auraient. et et ça
nous a interpellé, on a creusé les
choses. On a vu très récemment, il y a
un documentaire qui est sorti sur Amazon
concernant le disclosure, c'est-à-dire
la la chose révélée ou pas, où il y a le
Congrès américain, des membres du
Congrès américain qui sont questionnés,
ils sont questionnés concernant des
programmes financés pour s'intéresser
sur ce sujet-là et il y a tout un tas de
personnes qui parlent d'OVNI qui
surveilleraient nos centrales
nucléaires, nos lance-missiles
nucléaires et tout un tas de choses.
Mais tout ça
Jean-Pierre, attends.
Oui.
Euh, grâce à toi
euh nous on a fait une observation avec
un copain et grâce aux consignes de
sécurité que tu as laissé pour pouvoir
récupérer un témoignage propre, on a
fait chacun de notre côté, on euh je te
décris la chose, on a vu un truc passer
dans le ciel,
je lui ai dit "Tu vois ce que je vois ?"
Il m'a dit "Je vois." Je dis surtout me
décris rien, regarde bien et ensuite on
fera le dessin chacun de notre côté pour
éviter. On avait pas de bonnette pour
analyser le spectre mais on a fait un
dessin de chacun de notre côté qui
ressemblait à 98,9 % à au même objet
triangulaire avec trois feux rouges et
un feu blanc en dessous et on l' on a
bien eu le temps. Et donc à cause de ça,
de cette observation peut-être terrestre
ou peut-être d'ailleurs, on s'est dit on
va creuser plus le sujet. On a mis notre
communauté aussi à contribution pour
aller nous chercher des choses à lire,
des questionnements, des raisonnements
et on a fait venir le plus grand
astrophysicien français sur notre
plateau pour pouvoir nous en parler
parce que ça fait des années que tu
t'intéresses à ce sujet-là. Quand tu as
vu la vidéo de la Névi avec cette petite
chose au milieu, ça t'a fait penser à
quoi Jean-Pierre ? Mais je veux dire
toutes ça, ces aspects périphériques,
moi je suis un scientifique, hein. Euh
je veux dire que c'est pas la peine de
me demander si je crois à ceci, si je
crois à cela. Dans cette histoire-là,
par exemple, est-ce que les voyages
interstelles sont faisables ? Bon alors
on voit qu'actuellement c'est cette
longueur des voyages qui rend les
scientifiques sceptiques. Alors quand on
regarde le modèle Génus, le modèle Génus
l'univers a une sorte d'univers
parallèle dans lequel les longueurs sont
pas les mêmes mais la vitesse de lumière
est pas les mêmes. Et dans ce second
univers, les distances sont 100 fois
plus courtes et la vitesse de la lumière
10 fois plus élevée. Donc on gagne un
facteur 1000 sur les voyages sur les
temps de voyage. Donc en conséquence les
voyages intercellaires sont non
impossibles. D'ailleurs, j'ai fait une
bande dessinée justement le métaphysicon
et j'ai mis ces choses-là dedans. On
trouvera même des détails techniques
dans tout ça. Je pense que nous sommes à
moins d'un siècle de comprendre cette
technologie. Quand je vois des gens qui
imaginent euh les civilisations de type
1 2 3, c'est comme s'il fallait
mobiliser l'énergie du soleil entière
pour faire marcher un engin. Non, pas du
tout. Et vous avez même les explications
dans la bande dessinée.
Dans un truc comme ça, vous avez une
masse qu'il faut inverser. Alors, on
prend une masse M. Alors, un physicien
dira "Oui, mais il y a une énergie MC2,
c'est considérable ?" Non, non. C'est
expliqué dans la bande dessinée et c'est
c'est expliqué dans les textes des
lettres que j'ai reçu. Moi, je sais qui
était rigolo. Et à ce momentlà, il faut
focaliser de l'énergie sur une couche à
la périphérie. Alors, comment est-ce
qu'on focalise l'énergie ? Et bien, il
faut la mettre dans des atomes qui
peuvent pas s'en débarrasser. Ça
s'appelle les ées les atomes métalables.
Et dans des noyaux métalbles, il y a
même des détails qui sont donnés
là-dedans. Donc on a cette technologie
qui est au bout au bout de la plume. On
va trouver une chose pareille. C'est
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire. Donc on
est arrivé dans l'âge des voyages
interstelles. Alors, c'est là qu'à ce
moment-là, toute cette histoire-là nous
amène à un questionnement, on pourrait
dire philosophique, hein. Alors,
première chose que j'ai trouvé dans ces
textes, c'est que euh quand ces
extraterrestres arrivent sur terre, ils
sont très surpris parce qu'on a des
couleurs différentes. Il y a des noirs,
il y a des blancs, il y a des jaunes.
Première réaction, ils doivent se
peindre en noir le lundi, en jaune le
mercredi et cetera. Bon, ensuite les
langues, il y a des centaines de langues
complètement incroyable. Bon, ensuite,
un autre euh point très important, chez
vous, vous avez un biotope 100 fois plus
riche que chez nous. Et alors en ce
moment, on comprend la chose suivante.
Pourquoi ? Alors si on regarde le
système solaire et bien on a quatre
planètes telléluriques. On a la Terre,
on a Mars, on a Vénus et on a Mercure.
Ces quatre planètes sont solides. Les
autres on n'y a pas compte. C'est
planètes gazeuses. Et sur ces planètes
bien il y en a qu'une qui a une activité
tectonique importante qui a un Magma qui
bouge. Et effectivement quand on va sur
Mars, il y a un relief mais c'est un
volcan. C'est un volcan pourquoi ? parce
qu'il pleut pas sur Marx. S'il y avait
des précipitations en 3 mois, il y
aurait plus rien quoi. Ça aurait été
complètement dissous. Vénus c'est
pareil. Ce sont des planètes qui n'ont
pas de dérive des continents. Alors on
pourrait dire mais pour avoir une dérive
des continents, il faut qu'il y ait de
l'eau. Non pas du tout. Si on prenait la
terre et qu'on vaporise toute l'eau des
océans, mais on verrait [grognement]
très bien entre l'Afrique et l'Amérique
du Sud, il y a une fracture qu'on
appelle une dossiole médiaocéanique. Là
où les continents s'écartent, il y a une
cicatrice et ces dorsales médioéaniques
n'existent sur des autres planètes. Donc
on est la seule qui est contenue qui est
connue cette dérive des continents.
Maintenant cette dérive des continents,
elle est liée à l'activité du magma. On
est la seule planète qui a un magma
actif. Mais d'où ça vient ? Et bien ça
vient de la collision qui est donné
naissance à la lune. Et ça c'est
étonnant, c'est que les scientifiques
n'en parlent pas pratiquement. On a une
planète, je ne sais plus, on lui on l'a
appelé qui est un truc de la taille de
Mars qui arrive sur la Terre qui crée
une collision et cette collision
[grognement] crée un éject qui va créer
la Lune. Bon, c'est très bien mais cette
planète, elle arrive avec une énergie 1
demi de MV2. Cette énergie, il faut bien
qu'elle soit convertie quelque chose.
Vous savez quand la Terre était dans une
phase très primitive, quelqu'un qui
l'aurait vu aurait vu une planète
complètement rougeoyante parce que à
chaque fois qu'il y a des des objets qui
apportent un impact, ça réchauffe et
après ça se refroidit. Donc la Terre,
s'il y avait pas eu ce truclà, le magma
de la Terre se serait calmé. il y aurait
pas eu de dérive des continents. Or,
cette dérive des continents qui est du à
cette collision crée la chose suivante,
crée donc des mouvements
de de fracture. Et lorsque les
continents se chevauchent, c'est comme
les plaques de glace, c'est ça qui crée
les montagnes. Donc vous avez
l'urogénie, c'est-à-dire la création des
montagnes, vous avez la séparation des
biotopes et effectivement sur terre, on
pourrait dire que dire qu'il y a 500
biotopes différents, c'est logique.
Alors, il y a 500 biotopes c'estàd qu'on
a une richesse génétique, ce qui était
dit dans ces textes, tout règne
confondu, hein, végétaux, animaux, tout
ça, c'est un 500 fois plus riche sur les
autres planètes. Donc, on est amené à se
poser la question pour laquelle j'aurais
bien aimé que les scientifiques
réfléchissent.
Qu'est-ce qui serait arrivé à la Terre
s'il y avait pas eu cette dérive de
continent ? Et bien à ce moment-là, on
aurait un nombre d'espèces 500 fois plus
faible et on aurait une espèce humaine
également très appauvrie. Nous on a 500
ethnies, on n pas 500 races humaines
puisque maintenant ça se réduit à une
seule mais on aurait 500 ethnies et on a
500 langues différentes, on a 500
cultures différentes, on a 500 histoires
différentes et à ce moment-là on a des
conflits qui perdurent.
Vous comprenez ?
Donc pour toi, tu penses que l'humanité
a déjà été contactée ?
Elle qu'elle a été contexée par le
problème, c'est que toute cette histoire
là nous interroge sur le devenir général
des planètes.
Moi, j'ai écrit dans mes bouquins et je
le redis encore une fois, quand on
essaie de dire des choses qui sont pas
complètement stupides sur l'univers, on
se dit "Ben qu'est-ce que je pourrais
dire ?" Bah oui, ça accroit sa
complexité et ça étend son champ
relationnel. Au point de vue du vivant,
c'est exactement ce qui se passe. On
parle des des des cellules les plus
élémentaires. Maintenant, moi je peux
prendre mon téléphone portable et
appeler quelqu'un en Nouvelle-Calédonie
aux antipodes. Donc simplement, il y a
une il y a eu augmentation du champ
relationnel. Et là, la question qui est
posée au point où on en est, est-ce que
ça s'arrête ? Et si c'est un principe
général, si c'est justement ce qui est à
l'ave dans le cosmos et quand on
réfléchit même après au moment de la
jeunèse cosmique, ça on commence par
avoir des des protons qui se promènent
et des électrons qui se battent en duel.
C'est très élémentaire. Bon et bien tout
ça va créer de la complexité. La
complexité, c'est les étoiles qui vont
nous la créer. Ça va créer la table de
MLF. Autement dit, vous partez
[grognement] un un mélange de protons
d'électron et puis quelques milliards
d'années après, vous avez la table de
Mélf. C'est extraordinaire. Après cette
table de Mélief, elle est créée par les
supernovas. Après les planètes
apparaissent. Ces planètes font aussi de
la complexité. Et puis après et bien
tout d'un coup la vie apparaît et tout
ça ça procède du même phénomène entre ce
qui se passe dans le monde minéral, dans
le monde inerte qui va vers la
complexité, ça continue à travers le
biologique. Donc l'idée on pourrait dire
philosophique, c'est la chose suivante.
Bah peut-être que c'est le moteur de
l'univers. Effectivement, il devient de
plus en plus compliqué, il se
complexifie. Donc si c'est sa sa
tendance générale, il y a aucune raison
que ça s'arrête. Alors, à ce moment-là,
on dit "Oui, mais il y a quand même une
chose, c'est que euh regardez par
exemple euh il y a pas d'oiseau qui est
capable de nous apporter porter vers une
autre planète." C'est vrai que quand on
prend la Terre, bah au début la veille
la vie apparaît dans les océans et après
bah il y a une chose, les algues
fabriquent l'oxygène de manière à
envahir la terre. Donc, à ce moment-là,
la vie se propage sur à la surface de la
Terre. Puis alors après les animaux ont
des pâtes, ils ont des ailes, ils ont
des nageoires. Tout ça c'est fait pour
pouvoir se promener. Donc et vous avez
même des oiseaux qui arrivent à
traverser les océans. Mais
malheureusement pour le le le problème
interstellaire, le biologique ne suit
plus. [grognement] Donc il faut que à ce
momentlà qu'il y ait une solution autre
que le biologique. Et cette solution
autre que le biologique c'est la
technologie. Et c'est là que ça fait
percevoir la technologie comme quelque
chose de complètement à part. C'est un
phénomène émergent. Alors, on pourrait
dire "Vous êtes finaliste." Oui, je suis
finaliste au sens où je pense que c'est
pas un Dieu qui mène le monde, c'est ce
principe de monter vers la complexité,
l'extension du champ relationnel, on l'a
sous les yeux, le nier serait stupide.
Donc là, je dis simplement ça devrait
continuer, mais si ça doit continuer,
seule la technologie le permet. Et à ce
moment-là, on voit une chose, par
exemple, moi je me rappelle, j'avais un
vieil ami qui est mort maintenant, qui
était très spécialisé dans l'évolution.
Il disait dans le vivant, il y a une
chose, c'est que le hard est livré en
même temps que le soft. C'est-à-dire que
lorsque il y a un saut biologique qui
est qui est fait, il y a un attribut, un
organe et bien à ce moment-là la façon
de gérer l'organe et gérer avec que tout
fonctionne. Et là l'impression que ça
donne c'est que il y a un bipè nous nous
qui les animaux ont des technologies
primitives mais nous on a développé une
technologie simplement on ne comprend
pas à quoi ça sert et en fait cette
technologie c'est pour opérer des
voyages interstelles. C'est ça qui est
énorme. Et tout le reste, ce sont des
épisénomènes.
L'appartement dans lequel nous sommes,
la caméra pour nous filmer,
les lunettes du GAL, les appareils pour
surdo et cetera. Tout ça c'est des
épishénomènes et alors il y a aussi une
retombée qui est un épisénomène, c'est
la guerre. Mettez-vous à la place de
l'extraterrestre qui ont compris ça.
C'est dit mais ils ont pas encore
compris. Ils sont en train de se
sur la gueule comme des cons et là
actuellement. Je dirais même la
situation politique actuelle, elle est
elle est complètement surréaliste. On
arrive même à faire des guerres et
pourquoi est-ce que vous faites la
guerre ? Je ne sais pas, je on a eu
l'idée comme c'est extraordinaire. Et il
y a des morts et on continue. Regardez
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale, on a
eu autant de morts que durant cette
guerre. Je crois qu'on on compte 50
millions de morts avec toutes les
guerres qu'on a pu faire. Tout ça, ce
sont complètement inutiles. Il faudrait
pouvoir avoir un sifflet en en sifflant
de partie. tout si fa arrêtez les les
gars arrêtez vos fusils, vos avions. Moi
quand je vois des chasseurs de 6e
génération, moi qui fait super-héros, ça
m'emmerde parce que je me rends compte
que c'est fait pour tuer. C'est
inimaginable. Moi, il y a même une
chose, c'est quand je regarde les télés
et je vois des trucs, il y a des
émissions par exemple meurtre à
Besançon, meurtre à Carcasson, mais j'en
ai marre. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on nous
montre tout le temps des gens en train
de s'entretuer, quoi. Est-ce que vous
vous rendez compte de l'image que nous
donnons à des extraterrestres ? Regarde
notre télé. Vous avez vu la série toutes
les villes françaises y passent hein.
Meurtre à extrence, meurtre à Pertu. On
va continuer comme ça longtemps. Mais
mais c'est emmerdant. Même quand je vois
Hercule Poireau, ça m'emmerde moi, c'est
tout. Voilà. Donc vous voyez, c'est pas
le fait d'être un pacifiste Bellan, mais
toute l'énergie que l'humanité consomme.
Il y a une chose fantastique. Prenez par
exemple les avions de guerre. Vous
rendez compte ce que ça coûte ? Je crois
que un F35 ça vaut 500 millions de
dollars. Et vous construisez des
appareils, vous mettez des gens dedans
pour les casser. Exordinaire.
La guerre c'est un un truc dans lequel
on fait des objets très sophistiqués et
on les casse
un peu comme les drones.
Oui. Ouais. Mais c'est fou. C'est fou.
Revenons à notre sujet. Avant de rentrer
dans Janus. Euh
tu as bien vu les vidéos qu'on a pu voir
qui ont fait grand bruit. cette vidéo en
noir et blanc avec une caméra qui traque
à l'infrarouge, un espèce de gim qui
tourne avec un un hallo sur le côté. Tu
as tu as dû voir d'autres déclarations
ou d'autres témoignages de missile
nucléaires qui s'arrêtent
de choses qui survolaient des bases
atomiques. Tu parlais de guerre. Toi
quand tu vois ça, après on rentrera dans
le détail sur d'autres choses. Quand tu
vois ça médiatiquement parlant, quand ça
passe à la télé, ça te fait quoi ? De
ton regard de superhéros, tu dis ça
c'est propulsé comment ?
Ben moi, je te répondrai
et trois philosophiquement parlant,
qu'est-ce que ça implique ?
Bah simplement que on se demande
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra montrer au
terriens pour qu'il s'en aperçoivent
quoi. C'est inimaginable quoi. Vraiment
vraiment. Moi je pense que je souvent je
j'imagine ce qui se passerait si une
soucoupe volante se posait
sur la plaine de la bosse quelque part
quoi. Alors à ce momentlà les gendarmes
constatent, ils appellent le ministère
et à ce moment-là vous avez sécurisé.
Oui, on a sécurisé. Et alors imaginez
cette soucoupe qui stationne à 10 m à
quelques mètres au-dessus du sol. On ne
sait pas comment ni pourquoi mais on
peut pas s'en approcher parce que quand
on s'en approche qu'on a mal à la tête
et ça
où on se fait brûler
quoi
où on se fait brûler on se fait brûler
il y a eu des il y a eu des témoignag
par imaginez tout d'un coup que personne
ne peut s'approcher de la soucoupe. Tout
d'un coup il y a un chien qui arrive et
il va se mettre sous la soucoupe et il
la boit et visiblement les il y a
quelqu'un qui lu donne quelque chose à
manger. Alors il revient évidemment on
saute sur le chien. On va analyser le
chien et tout ça.
Imaginez la perturbation politique de
cet objet s'il restait
en quelques jours déjà il y a les
curieux qui arrivent mais en une semaine
vous avez les caméras de télé qui sont
coude à coude.
Vous avez les systèmes politiques qui
s'arrêtent c'est tout.
Et les systèmes religieux peut-être ?
Et les systèmes religieux. Exactement.
Moi je me rappelle Jacques Pradel a fait
des émissions. Il était allé, il m'avait
invité à ses émissions, il avait invité
le représentant de de la mouvance
catholique romaine. Je sais plus comment
il s'appelait. Et le type avait dit
"Mais moi, je ne sais pas du tout opposé
au fait que le Christ soit mort en croix
pour d'autres planètes. Mais quand on
voit le nombre de planètes, ça fait du
boulot, quoi." Alors, effectivement
là-dedans,
dans cette histoire-là, on évoque euh le
fait que le voyage à l'interstellaire,
ça ça constitue l'extension logique. La
guerre, c'est quelque chose, c'est du
temps perdu. On est en train de perdre
du temps, on perd de l'énergie. C'est
c'est idiot. On devrait envisager le
contact et euh regardz des gens comme au
King qui disaient "Oui, mais peut-être
que ces gens-là sont mal intentionnés,
mais s'il y avait vraiment
fondamentalement une mauvaise intention,
on le saurait déjà. Or, depuis 50 ans,
on n'est pas esclavagé. Simplement, on
se comporte comme des imbéciles. Alors,
j'ai vu une scène extraordinaire qui
date des années 60. C'est un type qui
est allé filmer une guerre papou. Donc
il est là avec sa caméra et il y a 300
mecs de chaque côté. Ils sont là avec
leur lance et [grognement]
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il y a eu trois
morts dans le camp adverse et ils sont
pendant 2 he oh et de temps en temps il
y en a un qui revient il a une flèche
plantée dans le cul alors il faut lui
enlever mais vous voyez mais quand on
voit un truc pareil quelle différence il
y a entre ces papous qui s'engueulent
comme des imbéciles et ce qu'on fait
maintenant c'est incroyable
depuis les 50 dernières années en terme
de divulgation d'information ou de de
témoignage qui a pu te piquer l'esprit,
qu'est-ce qui t'a le plus interpellé ?
C'est la dernière vidéo de la Névi avec
le petit truc qui tourne. C'est quand
quand tu as été faire des prélèvements
quand tuas quand tu as été faire des
prélèvements d'herb qui ont été
irradiés,
c'est c'est quoi ?
Mais non, c'est le coup de téléphone de
Demis. Mais voilà des informations dans
une pipe. Quand on montre une photo,
qu'est-ce que je peux en faire ? Hein ?
simplement, j'ai eu en main des
centaines de feuilles avec des des
histoires et puis des des coup.
Tu penses pas que c'était un canular ça
qu'on a essayé qu'on a essayé de te
discréditer pour que les États-Unis
puissent s'emparer de tes recherches sur
la MHD ?
Non mais attends, il y a un truc, c'est
il y a le document de 91 chez Berkov.
Chez Berkov, j'ai un beau costard, je
parle chez Berkov, je raconte ce que
Demigz a dit. Donc il y a une preuve, on
est comme dans un, il y a des pièces, ça
c'est une pièce 91, ça veut dire que
c'est 35 ans avant le papier sur les
plockstar. C'est ça le problème. C'est
ça qui est important. Je veux dire que
est-ce que est-ce que vous croyez que
cette photo est authentique ? Est-ce que
vous croyez que cette vidéo Mais j'en
sais rien mais je veux dire que
l'information est beaucoup plus
importante. Disons que un bout de papier
avec une équation, c'est plus parlant
pour moi que n'importe quel film. Est-ce
que tu as tu as étudié ou écouté les
déclarations d'un mec, un américain qui
s'appelle Bob Lazar ?
Ben oui, mais c'est pareil. Mais je
sais, je connais tout ça. Paren pour
notre communauté.
Est-ce que vous croyez que Lazar Mais je
ne crois rien. Je ne crois rien.
Simplement en en scientifique tout bête.
Un moment, j'ai été mis en contact avec
des trucs, mais je me rappelle, ça s'est
fait en 75. Mon ami Viton qui
malheureusement est mort il y a 2 ans un
jour me [grognement] dit tu sais Claude
Poer [raclement de gorge] a a ramené des
documents qui venaient d'Espagne qui
sont assez intéressant oh mais écoute tu
vas me montrer ça et à ce retrouve avec
une vingtaine de feuilles et je lis ça
comme on lirait la science-fiction puis
là j'ai trouvé des choses quand même
très intéressantes techniquement
techniquement moi je suis ingénieur je
suis ingénieur de l'aéronautique. Par
exemple, dans un truc comme ça, on dit
"Voilà, nous avons des matériaux qu'on
pourrait qualifier aujourd'hui
d'intelligence." C'est des textes de
1965. Qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un matériau
intelligent ? Et bien, quand on prend
une aile d'avion, ben il y a une chose,
c'est que elle fatigue plus au roulage
qu'en vol. Moi, j'ai appris ça quand
j'étais étudiant à superhéros. Quand un
avion sort du hangar et qui va vers la
route, et bien il est soumis à
descousses et ça fatigue plus ses
structures que le vol. Voilà hein. Donc
autrement dit, si on peut faire en sorte
que les vibrations ne se propagent pas,
on gagnerait beaucoup. Et à ce
moment-là, comment faire pour que les
vibration ne se propage pas ? Et bien, à
ce moment-là, on a un métal et dans ce
métal, on a des tubulures un peu comme
dans le tissu humain, mais qui font
quelques nanomètres de diamètre dans
lequel circule un fluide qui qu'on peut
faire passer de l'état liquide et
solide. Et quand on fait ça, on modifie
les propriétés métal mécaniques du
système. Bah, je peux vous dire que si
quelqu'un inventait un truc comme ça en
disant "Je sais fabriquer un métal, je
voilà cette technologie", mais les
avions peseraient 10 francs moins lourds
et l'industrie aéronautique leur ferait
des ponts d'or. Alors voilà, je je
trouve des choses comme ça. Je dis ça
c'est pas idiot quoi. Voilà,
ça c'était dans les papiers
mais bien sûr les papiers de 67 mais
mais il y en a des tonnes d'histoire
comme ça. Donc cette histoire également
de comment dire de
euh de collision avec la terre de du
fait qu'il y ait plus de de que le
biotope soit beaucoup plus riche. J'ai
trouvé ça intéressant. Alors je me suis
dit bon ben je vais y aller voir. Alors
à ce voyage, j'ai pris contact avec
Ribéra, j'ai connu tous ses braves
contactés. C'est passionnant un truc
pareil.
Donc contacter par qui ?
Mais j'en sais rien. C'est des gens ils
reçoivent des courriers par la poste.
Voilà. simplement ces couris contiennent
des informations intéressantes. Alors,
en plus, il y avait des choses
là-dedans. Il y avait euh euh
vous croyez qu'il y a qu'un seul univers
en fait, il y a un univers jumeau où le
temps va à l'envers. Et ce deuxième
niveau univers estantiomorphe, il a
fallu que je je cherche le terme dans le
dictionnaire. ça veut dire miroir. Donc
moi, j'avais des outils mathématiques à
l'époque. J'ai commencé à bidouiller
avec ça. Je crois que j'étais en contact
avec ces textes en 75. En 77, j'ai sorti
deux autos contreus de l'Académie des
Sciences grâce à l'norovit qui s'appelle
univers etiomorphe avec des temps
opposés. Et le 2e article a un titre
poétique univers en interaction avec
leur image dans le miroir du temps. À
cette époque-là, simplement du fait que
j'ai réussi à construire cette solution,
je me suis dit le bonhomme qui a écrit
ça, c'est pas le premier venu. Je prends
pas de je je ne fais pas d'a priori, je
conclus pas rapidement. Tu as essayé de
savoir si c'était un scientifique
terrien entre guillemets.
Mais ça ne peut être qu'un scientifique,
un type comme ça. Mais les scientifiques
font pas de cadeau comme ça hein. C'est
comme si on on te disait voilà, tu vas
dans telle banque, au 3è étage il y a un
couloir, au bout tu prends le 25e coffre
et puis il y a une combinaison à sep
chiffres. Voilà les cinq premiers. Et tu
essayes et la porte s'ouvre. Tu dis le
type connaissait la la communion du
coffre. Donc là il y a il y a un
scientifique derrière. Alors du coup,
j'ai me suis procuré d'autres textes.
J'ai appris que Ah oui, j'ai ça ça a été
intéressant. Euh il y a un texte qui
disait "La vitesse de la lumière était
plus importante dans le passé
cosmologiquement." Et ça dans un texte
de 65, je crois qu'il y a pas de
précédent. Même dans la science-fiction,
personne n'a jamais eu dit un truc
pareil. Donc moi, je commençais à
travailler un peu en cosmologie. Donc
j'ai essayé de bricoler, ça marchait pas
très bien et c'est là que j'ai fait mon
premier voyage à Madrid que j'ai
rencontré se nommé Dominguez et je lui
ai dit "Oui." Alors j'ai commencé à
regarder les la partie scientifique de
ces textes. Je trouvais ça assez
intéressant mais j'ai essayé la vitesse
de la lumière, j'ai pris une vitesse qui
est en sur R ou R étant le rayon de
l'univers. Ça marche pas très il m'a
fait la chose suivante. Il m'a dit "Oui,
j'ai vu tes courriers, je leur ai posé
la la question au téléphone. Ils m'ont
dit que c'était 1 sur √2 R hein. Ça
c'est quand même assez exotiétique. Et à
ce momentlà cette information là ça
permet des tas de choses. Ça ça ça
c'est on appelle ça la démerdante, hein.
Voilà, ça permet [grognement] de de
débrouiller le papier. Et j'ai commencé
à faire un travail là-dessus et en 88,
j'ai fait une publication de Moderne
Physi qui s'appelle modèle cosmologique
à constante variable, à vitesse de la
lumière variable. C'est quand même
énorme. Donc à ce moment-là, l'idée que
ce soit des étudiants euh de la fac de
Madrid qui fassent ça pour s'amuser,
c'est de la blague. Et c'est pas non
plus la CIA, c'est pas non plus le KGB.
Il y a quelque chose, il y a quelque
chose d'énorme. Voilà. Voilà.
Est-ce que tu penses que les
gouvernements ont été contactés ?
Contactés, j'en sais rien. Est-ils ont
récupéré des choses.
Quand tu me dis "Est-ce que tu penses ?"
Moi je Un scientifique, il a pas à
penser, il a pas à croire. simplement,
il y a des faits, hein. Voilà, j'ai pris
tel piège, j'ai mis là-dedans, ça
rentre, ça fonctionne. Voilà, c'est
tout. Donc moi, j'ai des éléments
mathématiques que j'ai mis ensemble, ça
marche. Voilà. Voilà. Et j'ai même fait
un truc, c'est qu'à un moment, il y a un
problème mathématique qui avait l'air
tout à fait insoluble et j'ai eu
communication par téléphone de la
solution et j'ai fait une publication,
ça c'est des mathématiques venues
d'ailleurs. Voilà. J'ai mis une vidéo au
Janus qui s'appelle comme ça et quand on
regarde cette solution, on sait même pas
d'où elle sort et ça marche. C'est
magique
au téléphone.
Oui.
Ça ressemblait à quoi ? C'était une voix
d'homme, de femme ?
Une une voix d'homme qui parle un peu
comme une voix de canard. Voilà, c'est
tout. Mais mais je veux dire, ne me
demande pas des détails de genre quand
je quand il y a des courriers, qui
est-ce qui envoyait ? Est-ce que tu as
gardé l'enveloppe ? Mais non, ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est le contenu
scientifique.
Est-ce que la police s'est intéressée à
ça ?
Quoi ?
Est-ce que la police s'est intéressé à
ça ? Est-ce [grognement] qu'ils t'ont
demandé de relever les empreintes ?
Est-ce qu'ils t'ont essayé de Ils ont
essayé de voir qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
derrière ?
Personne personne n'a rien fait. Mais il
y a il y a quand même une chose
extraordinaire là. tes tes lecteurs
quand même vont être contents, quoi. Bah
euh donc à un moment dans ces textes là,
je trouve que euh la science terrestre
ferait de plus de progrès si elle
abandonnait cette logique divalente avec
le vrai et le faux. On a un principe, le
principe du tiers exclu, soit c'est
vrai, soit c'est faux, mais il y a pas
de situation intermédiaire. Or, en fait,
quand on prend le langage humain, ça
abom.
Par exemple, si je dis je mens, voilà
une promotion indécidable. Est-ce que
quand je dis, est-ce que c'est vrai ?
parce que si c'est vrai, c'est faux et
si c'est faux, c'est vrai et cetera.
Donc ça tourne en rond. Et alors à ce
moment-là, il y a un grand logicien qui
s'appelle Kurt Guedel qui était un
copain d'Instein qui était à l'Institut
des études avancées de Princeton qui a
cherché un langage dans lequel euh il y
avait pas de proposition indécidable
comme ça. Alors il s'est dit bon ben je
vais prendre le langage le plus simple
c'est l'arithmétique quand on dit c'est
simple comme de et de font tr hein et
ben à ce moment-là il s'est mis
là-dedans. Je vais pas rentrer dans le
détail parce que là c'est des
mathématiques que les gens vont pas
comprendre. Mais il y a une chose c'est
que Godel a montré que l'arithmétique
était indécidable. Par exemple, voyez
dans l'arithmétique on peut tout réduire
à 0 et 1 un langage binaire. Alors à ce
s'il avait fait une sorte de machine
comme un tiroir caisse avec deux
touches. Il y a une touche 0, une touche
et 1. Alors à ce moment-là, il tape 0 =
0 puis il tourne la manivelle. Ah, il
sort 1, c'est vrai. Ah, c'est vrai. Bon,
alors est-ce que 1 est égal à 1 ? C'est
vrai. [grognement] Maintenant, est-ce
que 0 est égal à 1 ? Vrai, faux, vrai,
faux, ça se met à clignoter. Donc voilà.
Donc il y a un problème de
d'indécidabilité.
Moi, je me suis mis là-dedans, j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant. Je me suis dit
mais est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose de
plus de plus général, de plus profond
que l'arithmétique ? Et bien oui, c'est
les ombres inventés par le mathématicien
gauche qui s'appelle les entiers de
gauche, c'està-dire les entiers
complexes. Quand on prend les nombres
entiers, c'est comme si on prenait un
fil et qu'on met des perles, hein. Les
nombres, c'est ils sont les uns derrière
les autres. Mais quand on prend ces
cette succession de nombre, et bien on
peut l'imaginer au contraire un
quadrillage. Et à ce moment-là, on au
lieu de pointer un nombre, on pointe un
point sur le cadr et ça c'est beaucoup
plus subtil. Et à ce moment-là, je me
suis aperçu que la logique de cette
histoire-elà n'existait pas. Et 4 ou 5
jours après, j'ai reçu un courrier
d'Arabie Saoudite disant "Vous avez mis
dans le 1000." Voilà. Voilà. Bon,
pourquoi d'Arabie Saoudite ?
Quoi ?
Pourquoi d'Arabie Saoudite ?
J'en sais rien. Ça venait de Riad. Mais
après,
c'était écrit comment ? En anglais, en
français ?
C'est écrit en français mais là encore
une fois euh peu importe quoi. Le
problème c'est est-ce qu'on arrive à
faire fonctionner les choses ? Moi quand
je reçois des informations de ce genre,
je me dis soit je les comprends, soit je
les comprends pas. Et puis si je les
comprends pas, je vais les mettre sur
une étagère peut-être que ça leur
donnera quelque chose. Voilà, donc c'est
tout une notion le vrai et le faux, ce
que je pense, ce que je ne pense pas, ce
que je crois, ce que je crois pas. Non.
Est-ce que c'est fonctionnel ? Est-ce
que ça marche ? La réponse, ça a marché
au-delà de tout ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer. Voilà, c'est ma réponse.
On va éviter de faire une courbe de liss
à jou sur ma question. C'est comment une
courbe de lis à jou ? Courbe de Je me
rappelle plus comment c'est fait une
Oui. [rires]
Non mais voilà. Donc je te repose ma
question Jeanpierre là on voit beaucoup
de choses. On voit beaucoup de
politiques parler, on voit beaucoup
d'étatsmajors parler, on voit beaucoup
de scientifiques parler autour
d'une déclassification
d'une partie des choses, de certains
projets américains pour enquêter,
financé par le Congrès américain, des
choses comme ça, des survols de central
nucléaire, de base nucléaire domicile et
de tout un tas de choses connectées avec
le nucléaire.
Toi quand tu vois ça que tuentends, il y
a eu tant de survol, il y a eu tant de
missiles désactivés où il y a eu une
observation d'un tic-tac géant, une
observation d'un truc qui viendrait pas
de chez nous, ni par la magie du
Saint-Père.
Alors
et la question c'est alors toi ça te
fait peur ? Tu t'y attends ?
C'est-à-dire que les gouvernements
disent à leurs
ils sont là depuis longtemps
ou tu penses que c'est une diversion ?
Moi je vous dis la chose suivante, c'est
que j'étais en contact direct avec des
gendarmes qui sont chargés de la
surveillance des réacteurs nucléaires.
Les récits que j'ai pu avoir de ces
gens-là dépassent l'imagination. Ils ont
dit qu'ils avaient vu un truc mais à 15
m du sol et cetera et cetera. Donc le
fait que
ça ressemblait à quoi ? Quoi ?
Ça ressemblait à quoi ? Oui. Le mieux
c'est le triangle. B le le mais peu
importe à quoi ça ressemble, ils ont
vraiment été en contact avec des choses
comme ça et puis ils étaient là les
autres, il y a eu un film et cetera.
Mais ce que je peux vous dire, écoutez
bien, c'est que tout ce que vous envoyez
comme des pseudos réévélations, ça ne
marchera pas. Les Américains font des
auditions au Congrès, on fait venir des
gens et ça tourne en rond. Ça ça
n'aboutira jamais. Ils ont des dossiers,
ils ont tout ce qu'on veut mais ça ne
donnera strictement rien. Le projet
Cométait pareil. Tout ça, tout ça c'est
c'est quoi le projet Cométa ? Ben
le projet Coma, c'est quatre officiers
supérieurs qui sont dit "On va essayer
de bouger les choses." Alors ils ont
fait un truc mais à chaque fois ça
n'aboutit pas c'est tout. Mais
ils ont essayé de prévenir Fabius et
Chirac. Ils ont dit ils ont dit que
l'espace aérien français était traversé.
Ce qui est important, c'est ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis. Alors, à ce
moment-là, nous allons donner la parole
au général Machin qui est à la retraite,
à mon général. Oui. Alors, qu'est-ce que
vous avez à dire ? Et bien, je dois vous
dire que c'est quelquefois j'ai vu
passer des dossiers qui qui étaient
intéressants quoi. On ça jamais plus
loin, quoi. Et quand un type a quelque
chose à dire, tout d'un coup, il
s'arrête. Non, c'est la censure totale.
Moi, je sais que j'ai essayé mais j'ai
essayé de d'être interview par des
blogueurs américains, il y en a comme
Jess Michel,
Kurt Gmingal et tout ça. Les rendez-vous
étaient pris, c'était ils se sont
décommandés la veille. G M'a dit "Oui,
pour l'interview qu'on doit faire
demain, ma mère vient d'avoir un AVC
donc ah ben je OK, problème de forche
majeure. Alors les mois passent, je
reprends contact, il me dit "Ah, je vous
remercie pour votre patience." Et je dis
"Oui, mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
l'interview ?" "Ah ben tout est pris
jusqu'à fin 2025." Je dis "OK, alors
prenons date pour 2026." Mais non,
silence. Et je peux lui envoyer
n'importe quoi. C'est le silence pareil
sur le gichel. pareil pour tous en
Amérique, je sais pas mais vous savez le
truc c'est que si quelque chose bouge,
ce sera aux États-Unis. Regardez ce qui
se passe actuellement politiquement. Il
y a des gens tout d'un coup qui qui
parlent ouvertement du fait que les
Trump a été manipulé par les Israéliens,
mais ce sont les Américains qui en
parlent, c'est pas les Français. Il y a
des gens et aux États-Unis, on a des euh
des il y a comment s'appelait le le
policier incorruptible, les
incorruptibles. Voilà, mais on a des
gens comme ça aux États-Unis. Chez nous,
il n'y a pas si nous on a des petits
bons hommes, on va jamais très très
loin.
T'explique cette censure comment et
pourquoi ? Cette censure comment et
pourquoi ?
Mais parce que c'est extrêmement
déstabilisant. C'est déstabilise tout
mais c'est inimaginable. Il y a une
censure scientifique, ça c'est évident.
Il y a une censure politique, une
censure religieuse, tout. Comment
voulez-vous faire euh émerger un
problème qui va être un séisme ? C'est
pas possible. Un truc pareil. Et alors
moi je faudra que je trouve moi je
dirais que dès les années je me suis dit
la meilleure façon d'attraper un deven,
c'est une feuille de papier un crayon.
Voilà hein. Hein voilà. effectivement
euh papier crayon des maths, une
publication et cette publication sur les
plug stars et tout mon modèle
cosmologique c'est un document tout ça
c'est beaucoup plus pesant que toutes
les photos de la terre que tous les
témoignages de la terre.
On va revenir sur ton modèle juste un
peu plus tard. Tu penses que les
États-Unis ou d'autres puissances ont
récupéré des aéronefs pour faire du
rétroengineering et ensuite faire des
choses mine
en tout cas s'ils l'ont fait ils sont
pas bien démerdés he je je dis [rires]
mais il y a il y a un truc par exemple
c'est que euh
l'antigravité
quoi
oui alors l'antigravité c'est pas idiot
parce que quand on prend une massème et
qu'on l'inverse ben elle est repoussée
par la terre puis après si on l'inverse
de nouveau, on fait alterner sa sa
pesanteur et finalement elle bouge pas.
Voilà. Mais tout ça, on a ça au bout de
la plume.
Je sais pas mais les Français sont donc
très avancés dans ce domaine.
Grâce à toi.
Grâce à moi. [rires]
Non mais
parle-moi de la MHD. C'est quoi la MHD ?
Ah la MHD, bah la MHD euh
al ça va ça va nous amener dans un p de
ma carrière scientifique. Bon, on a le
temps. Bon, d'accord. Alors euh moi je
je fais superhéros puis j'ai pas
vraiment envie d'être ingénieur donc je
commence par être graveur sur cuivre et
lithographe pendant quelques années puis
ça marche pas très bien. Bon j'ai une
femme un enfant donc obligé de
travailler. Donc je je prends un boulot
puis finalement j'atterris au CNRS où on
me donne le texte d'un contrat juste une
page il fallait faire marcher une
machine avec deux températures. C'est
pas mal un truc comme ça. Et je crois
que dans le laboratoire où j'étais, les
gens ne comprenaient même pas ce que ça
voulait dire. Bon, alors moi, je regarde
tout ça et j'étais en contact avec le
mathématéticien les Schneurovitz. Donc
déjà à l'époque, j'étais un peu euh
attiré par les maths. Et là ce que j'ai
compris c'est que c'est un problème qui
ne pouvait se gérer que dans un espace à
cette dimension
qui est l'espace dans lequel on peut
avoir des températures différentes quoi.
Donc à ce moment-là, j'ai créé euh une
expérience, j'ai conçu une expérience
avec le calcul. Et c'est vrai que quand
on est physicien, si on veut vraiment
faire du bon boulot, il faut maîtriser
l'expérience et maîtriser la théorie qui
va avec. sinon ça marche pas. Et ça a
donné une expérience qui s'est faite un
jour et malheureusement il est mort. Mon
ami Inglésakis était présent et on avait
donc un canon à plasma. C'est un peu
comme si on était des artilleurs quoi.
On avait une culasse avec un canon. On
chargeait le canon bom pour tirer et on
envoyait un plasma à 3 km par seconde et
au bout on avait un générateur
électrique qui produisait des courants
électriques et ça marchait à 10000°. Et
moi j'ai dit à Inglise à Kiss, on va
mettre 6000°gr seulement. Il dit il y
aura rien. Si si, je t'assure. Et alors
on a mis 6000°. Il n'y croyait pas. Mais
au 3è essai, on a mis les
on a réglé les appareils de mesure, on
avait 8000 ampères. Donc autrement dit,
ça a marché au premier essai et c'est ça
qui est formidable. Et j'ai fait
quelques expériences de physique qui ont
qui ont de l'importance. Elles sont
toujours marchées au premier essai. qui
et en fait c'est tellement subtile que
si ça marche pas marché ça marchera
jamais quoi.
Qu'est-ce qu'on aurait pu faire avec ce
type de technologie si on t'avait donné
les budgets ?
Le le truc c'est que quand on dispose
d'un flux de gâcho chaud qui est porteur
d'électron et bien on peut utiliser son
énergie cinétique pour faire du courant
électrique. Alors le premier qui a fait
ça c'est l'anglais [grognement] faradis
au 17e siècle. Bon et les gens ont eu
l'idée de tenter ça dans les années 60
dans l'après-gerre. Donc beaucoup de
pays se sont lancé l'Alland. Les
Américains, les Français, les Russes,
les Polonais, plein [grognement] et le
problème [raclement de gorge] c'est que
ça ne marche que si le fluide est
suffisamment conducteur d'électricité.
Or un fluide, un gaz, c'est pas
conducteur d'électricité. Alors quand on
prend des gaz de tuyère, on aura pas
température pas plus que qu'un 100
2000°. Donc, on n pas à atteindre le
seuil de température en question. Et à
ce moment-là, quelqu'un a dit "Mais
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas faire marcher
ça avec une température électronique
élevée, mais la température glace plus
basse ?" Alors, on pe dire "Mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce fluide où il
y a une température électronique élevée,
une température basse ?" Mais c'est un
tube fluorescent. Quand vous prenez un
tube fluorescent, le gaz d'électron est
à des milliers de degrés mais vous
mettez la main dessus, il est froid.
Donc là, vous avez typiquement un gaz à
deux températures. Donc simplement, il
fallait fabriquer ce gaz à température
mais avec une pression importante. Donc
ce qui ce qu'il fallait faire
avec le avec ce type de technologie.
Alors avec ça, on pouvait faire disons
que le générateur qu'on avait avec Link
des Akis, il avait à peu près la taille
d'une canette de bière et il sortait 2
MW. Voilà. Voilà 2 MW dans un truc grand
comme ça. Alors c'est ça le côté de la
MHG. en plus avec un rendement de de 70
% quoi. C'était magnifique. Donc il y a
il y avait de l'argent derrière tout ça.
L'industrie était passionné par ça. Mais
bon sans trouver nous un moyen pour que
ça fonctionne et c'est là que ça pose le
problème de la gestion de la recherche
en France. On a abandonné cette MHD qui
a coulé comme le Titanic. Et alors à
part en France on construisait le
générateur Tifé. Tifé, c'est un c'est un
géant de de la mythologie grecque. C'est
un un géant des tempête tifé et Tifé n'a
jamais fait un pai de lapin le le tifé
français. Donc on avait construit tout
cet appareil avec dépose d'argent
considérable et tout ça ça finit par
être abandonné. On a donné ça à la
pioche et moi j'étais là en disant mais
mais oui mais moi ça marche mais
personne ne m'entendait. Et ça c'est
vraiment un truc, je me suis dit on peut
pas continuer à faire de la recherche
avec un gouvernement qui change d'avis
tous les 5 ans. C'est pas possible quoi.
Donc je me suis dit comment est-ce qu'on
peut se lancer dans un thème de
recherche en étant sûr de pouvoir
continuer sa voix et ben dans les maths.
C'est le seul endroit. Et moi,
j'ouvre une parenthèse sur les maths.
Là, aujourd'hui, le monde traverse une
grave crise énergétique où on commence à
peine à comprendre que ça va secouer
très fort.
Bien sûr.
Toi,
est-ce que tu penses que le monde va
pouvoir se donner des micro mini
générateurs MHD pour pouvoir palier à ça
? Non, le générateur MHD c'est pas la
solution parce que euh Non, mais le truc
c'est que moi j'ai l'impression de pas
être dans mon époque quoi disons hein.
Voilà,
je te rassure, ça nous fait ça à tous.
Voilà. Je sais pas mais euh je peux pas
regarder les terriens autrement qu'avec
une sorte de regarde d'extraterrestre en
disant "Mais mes pauvres enfants, vous
avez des solutions technologiques
tellement énormes dans les les 50 100
années qui viennent. Qu'est-ce que vous
êtes en train de vous emmerder avec des
avec ce que vous faites actuellement ?
C'est pas la MHD, c'est pas le
nucléaire. Il y a mieux que ça. Il y a
mieux que ça. Mais oui.
C'est quoi mieux ?
Bah le mieux c'est disons que euh quand
on a inventé le nucléaire, ça a été fait
par des chimistes hein. Et par exemple
la fission qui est la façon dont dont on
produit de l'énergie, c'est la première
fois qu'on se met à transformer de la
masse en énergie. Et il y a un truc, un
chiffre peut-être que les gens
connaissent. Quand on a fait exploser la
bombe d'Hirashima, on a converti une
certaine quantité de matière en énergie
et bien c'était 0,7 g. Voilà. Donc
simplement ce que je vous dis, un jour
nous saurons convertir la matière en
énergie directement.
Alors est-ce que vous vous rendez compte
si tout d'un coup on sait convertir 100
g d'énergie mais on alimente l'Europe
entière, c'est tout. Voilà, on a on age
dans les dans les solutions.
Philosophiquement parlant, quand on on
aura peut-être cette technologie
disponible, nous sommes une société une
société de transformants, de
consommants. Si on donne l'énergie
pratiquement gratuite et illimitée à ce
type de peuple, tu anticipes quoi avec
ça ?
Mais la question c'est pas ça, c'est que
si les gens si les gens connaissent la
façon de transformer les masses en
énergie, la première chose qu'ils vont
faire mais c'est des armes. Et ça, je
suis le témoin
formel sur ces questions par rapport à
ce qui sait en France. Le seul moment où
le sujet OVNI a eu une écoute, c'est des
gens en disant "Est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire des armes ?" C'est ça, c'est tout.
Et pourquoi est-ce que ça a foiré en
France ? Pourquoi tout est parti en
Russie ? C'est parce que j'étais pas du
tout branché armement.
Tu as été démarché pour faire de
l'armement ?
Bah disons que comment moi ce qui me
branchait c'était de supprimer les zes
de choc. Et pourquoi ? Parce que le
phénomène OVNI est interpelle de ce
côté-là. Il y a des gens qui voient
passer des trucs très rapidement, on
entend rien. Alors, je me rappelle avec
Viton en 1975, qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ?
On a fait une expérience en supprimant
la turbulence. Et la turbulence, c'est
une source de bruit. Donc déjà quand ce
trucl marchait, c'était passionnant.
Après on a supprimé une vague d'étraves
et cetera. Mais je veux dire que l'idée
de faire des armes ne me venait pas à la
tête. Alors que la dernière réunion qui
a eu lieu à Rouan, quand on reprend
toute la saga, lamentable de toute cette
histoire, j'étais face à des militaires.
Il y en a un qui a dit "Oui, avec ça, on
pourrait faire un missile hypersonique."
C'est en quelle année ?
Ben je crois que c'était en 83 chose
comme ça. Voilà. quand on a tout
abandonné. Mais je sais pas, je me
rappelle d'un type qui connaissait bien
Alari et Ali Marie regardait mon site
internet en disant "Ah s'il avait voulu
travailler pour nous." Mais moi je suis
le type ingérable. Comment faire pour le
faire travailler pour être ça
l'intéresse pas c'est tout ça ? Et
encore maintenant, j'ai des coups de
téléphone de gens qui veulent créer des
groupes de travail là-dessus sur ces
domaines. Alors, je vais me raconter une
anecdote qui est assez rigolote. Donc, à
un moment, Poutine annonce donc à la
Duma euh nous avons créé des armements
complètement nouveaux et nous avons créé
des missiles person qui vont à Magne 15
en herdance et cetera. il a parlé du
planeur hypersonique avant-garde euh et
cetera et il a parlé d'un missile de
croisière à propulsion super nucléaire
et cetera. Moi, je comprends tout ça
immédiatement et euh j'ai fait quelques
remarques vidéos en expliquant tout ça
et puis il y a des gens qui ont dit
"Oui, mais comme d'habitude, il délire."
Bon, mais il s'est passé la chose
suivante, c'est que les Français
surveillent l'atmosphère
vis-à-vis des émanations radioactive.
Mais si vous revenez à, j'ai pas
exactement le sens des dates, mais un
moment les Russes ont essayé ce genre de
de comment dire de propulseur nucléaire
et le truc a explosé et comme il est
propulsé avec des isotopes particuliers,
ça a donné des rejets que les gens ont
pu mesurer. Donc à ce moment-là, les
services secrets ont dit il y a eu ces
rejets, ça va de pair avec ce que disait
petit. Donc il doit avoir raison. Alors
à ce moment-là, un jour, un type me
téléphone en me disant voilà, je je suis
je voudrais vous rencontrer. [toux]
C'est un type de du cercle des
recherches militaire. Les autres lui
disent "Mais ne va pas le voir, il est
gérable, il va te jeter." Non non, on
l'a très bien reçu. J'ai une épouse
absolument charmante qui fait très bien
la cuisine. Alors, on l'avait invité à
déjeuner, il est arrivé à 11h. S'il
avait pu arriver à 10h, il serait arrivé
10h. Il est arrivé à 11h, il est reparti
à 6h du soir. On l'a invité à déjeuner.
Ce qui était assez marrant, c'est
qu'assez rapidement, il m'a dit "Voilà
euh on s'est rendu compte qu'on on vous
a maltraité
et on a on est complètement passé à côté
de la plaque. Alors, on voudrait se
remettre en chale en MHD. Ce qu'on vous
propose, c'est un rapport de vous nous
faites un petit rapport de 20 pages pour
3000 €." Carrément et je ne dis pas non.
Alors comme je dis pas non, il pense que
ça alors à ce moment-là il commence à
écubrer en France, on crée une pyramide
immédiatement avec des des chefs, des
sous-chefs, des trucs, des machins. Moi,
j'étais au milieu de tout ça. Contrôlé
l'identité du mec pour savoir s'il
bossait vraiment pour les Français ou
s'il bossait pour les Chinois. Non, non,
mais ça c'est c'est cétait il y a pas de
problème. C'est pas un plaisant. Voilà.
Et alors euh le truc c'est que à la fin
de la journée, il avait écubré tout un
système dans lequel je serais venu pour
former les militaires français et tout
ça. Je lui dis mais vous savez le truc
c'est que même si je voulais ce petit
rapport de 20 pages, il vous servira à
rien. Rendez-vous compte la MHD que je
faisais avec Viton, c'est à peu près la
technologie de Rutherford en 1905 hein.
Hein ? Voilà. Et et la différence entre
cette MHD là et ce que font les Russes,
c'est la comparaison entre Rutherford et
Cadarche par exemple. He voilà. Alors
par exemple, oui,
on a appris qu'il y a des gens qui
tiraient de l'énergie de l'atome. Alors,
est-ce que vous pourriez nous faire un
petit rapport pour nous expliquer ce que
c'est qu'un atome ? 20 pages pour 3000 €
voyez. Et alors, comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait tirer de l'énergie du nucléaire
? Bah, j'ai dit ma réponse est simple,
c'est 1000 personnes pendant 30 ans.
Voilà. Et oui hein, imaginez un pays qui
connaît Scodal sur la physique
nucléaire. Vous voulez tout faire à
partir de zéro et arriver à Cadarche,
bon bah 1000 personnes pendant 30 ans,
ça ça se fait pas en 15 jours. Voilà. Et
le train est manqué. En plus, c'est pas
plus mal parce que moi je me rappelle
souvent
euh euh juillet a parfaitement compris
que de ce côté-là on a quelque chose à
la juillet, mais il est quand même axé
sur la défense quoi. Et acte, ben c'est
normal, mais je veux dire les gens
pourraient dire "Vous rendez compte si
Jean-Pierre Petit avait été écouté, nous
aurions des armes et alors ?"
C'est pas le problème. C'est pas d'avoir
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? On va encore,
on va se doter de missile hupersonique.
Les Américains vont faire pareil. Mais
arrêtons nom de Dieu. Alors le problème
c'est qui est-ce qui peut proposer qu'on
arrête ? Qui est-ce qui va avoir cette
cette idée là ? Alors c'est là que on
est obligé de franchir un cran suivant.
Et ce cran suivant ça correspond à cette
bande dessinée, le métaphysicon que j'ai
sorti. Alors j'avais commencé par faire
un livre, malheureusement il était cigné
par un personnage pas très sympathique
donc ça a foiré. Mais cette bande
dessinée, la bande dessinée finalement
une bonne solution pour mettre des idées
là-dedans. Alors, je disais tout à
l'heure que l'univers finalement euh il
augmente son champ relationnel en se
complexifiant. Les deux sont liés. Bon,
maintenant euh
en 2018, j'ai un échange téléphonique
la nuit [rires]
avec des petits hommes verts.
Ben, je sais pas si s'ils sont verts,
j'en sais rien. Mais euh
la conversation tournait autour du de la
situation assez pitoyable de la planète
Terre, quoi.
Et Jean-Pierre, je peux te mettre une
parenthèse
quoi ? Je peux te mettre une parenthèse,
une micro parenthèse.
Quand tu reçois ce genre de coup de fil,
tu as pas pensé à appeler la DGSI en
disant les écoutez les gars, il faut me
remonter cet appel parce que c'est
peut-être une puissance étrangère qui
cherche à me faire tourner la tête ou à
m'extirper de l'information. Ce serait
bien que vous, mes services de
renseignement, vous me protégiez.
Mais non, mais non, mais le problème
n'est pas là. Le problème, qu'est-ce que
contient ce coup de téléphone ? de Dieu,
c'est toujours pareil, hein. Alors, à ce
moment-là, vous devriez avoir une
théorie de la de la croyance. Une
théorie de la croyance, qu'est-ce que
c'est qu' un truc pareil ? Oui. Oui.
Alors, vous avez travaillé 20 ans avec
le professeur Sorio, donc vous avez
utilisé ces techniques d'action
coadjointe d'un groupe sur les son
espace sur son algèbre de lit. Enfin, un
truc très compliqué. Bon, refaites la
même chose avec un espace de Ah,
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un espace deite ?
Je vais regarder
mais cette conversation c'était 3h du
matin. Au lev du jour, j'avais fini les
calculs. C'est pas que je vais
rapidement c'est que c'était
passionnant. Et là c'était complètement
fantastique. C'est-à-dire que
cette façon de voir de Suriot, ça
consiste à dire "Donnez-moi un espace,
je vais vous dire ce qu'il y a dedans."
Alors prenons l'espace clidien, trois
dimensions, on est censé vivre. Bon
voilà. Bon bah quand on prend l'espace,
il a des propriétés géométriques. Donc
Suriot prend son chapeau de magicien et
il dit "Ah il y a des sphères, ah il y a
des plans. Ah il y a des droites. Bon ça
a l'air comme ça évident. Mais quand on
prend l'espace de Minkowski, c'est
l'espace de l'indivité restreinte. Et à
ce moment-là ce ru fait ah il y a des
masses. Ah il y a des photons. Ça c'est
très fort. Et ça ça date de 1970. Et
alors cette technique là, ça consiste à
dire l'espace dans lequel on vit n'est
pas un espace de Mikowski. C'est c'est
plus compliqué que ça. C'est un espace
complexe. Et un espace complexe et bien
quand on prend la technique du on dit
"Ah, j'ai des masses réelles et j'ai des
masses imaginaires."
Des masses imaginaires, ça veut dire que
l'univers est double. C'est il a une
version tangible et puis une version
soft
la l'explication vous tout le monde
maintenant est familiarisé avec
l'informatique. Vous avez votre portable
devant vous. Le portable c'est des
atomes. Il a du hard. Bon mais vous
savez bien qu'il y a aussi une chose qui
n'est pas tangible qui est le soft et
vous-même les êtres humains, vous êtes
fait d'atomes, vous êtes vous êtes fait
de molécules mais vous avez aussi
quelque chose d'autre. C'est votre
pensée et bien c'est pas des ça ne se
limite pas à des jeux de charge
électrique dans votre cerveau. C'est
tout. Quand tu reçois un coup de fil
comme ça en pleine nuit,
tu décroches et c'est genre "Allô
Jean-Pierre avec la petite
la petite voix la petite voix naasde ou
vous avez un code entre vous ou tu
l'appelles comment
Mais j'en sais riel le problème c'est
que ça dure très peu de temps. Ils ont
pas de temps à perdre nom de Dieu.
Donc donc ça dure très peu de temps.
C'est tu décroches et là et là je me
suis fait engueuler parce que j'avais
envie de dormir et la voix protestait en
disant il faut que tu notes parce que tu
vas tu vas oublier le lendemain. Voilà.
Non mais voilà.
Qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il te disent
d'autres ? Qu'est-ce qui t'
Bah cette idée-là ça ça veut dire que
l'univers, il est fait de plusieurs
entités. Il y a euh
le hard, c'est c'est le plancher des
vaches et puis il y a les vaches et il y
a l'esprit des vaches. Autrement dit,
mais c'est pas moi qui a inventé ça. Je
crois que l'inventeur du nom c'est
[grognement] euh euh comment il
s'appelait ? C'est la NOSPhère. J'oublie
le nom de ce philosophe chrétien là.
Tard de chardin. C'est terrdin qui a
inventé la Nosphère. La Nosphère. ça
veut dire l'esprit en grec. Autrement
dit, on a un univers matériel
et puis donc un univers inanimé. Un
univers inanimé. Quand vous prenez un
morceau de un caillou, il y a il y a pas
d'armes là-dedans. Maintenant, quand
vous prenez la la
biosphère, c'est une sorte
d'intermédiaire. Il y a autre chose qui
est unehère. Et en fait l'anosphère et
la et la géosphère évoluent toutes les
deux en se complexifiant.
Et [grognement] ça c'est une idée
philosophique très intéressante, c'est
que
le monde l'univers est double et au
moment de sa création, au moment du big
bang, il est amorphe au point de vue des
masses. Il y a juste des protons, une
soupe de protons et d'électrons
indifférenciés. Et bien l'univers ne
pense pas. Comment voulez-vous qu'il
pense ? Puisque il s'est rien passé,
hein.
L'univers n'a pas de souvenir parce
qu'il y a pas d'événement,
il y a pas de pensée puis qu'il y a pas
d'objet. Donc philosophiquement, c'est
vachement intéressant. Donc on a un
univers métaphysique qui a tendance à se
développer en se conflexifiant et un
hiers physique. Et tout d'un coup, la
biosphère c'est le lien entre les deux
et ça permet une évolution beaucoup plus
rapide.
Donc revenons à ton coup de fil de la
nuit.
Ouais.
Ça arrive quelle fréquence ?
J'en sais rien. C'est c'est pas c'est
rare des choses comme ça. Mais
et tu notes est-ce que tu as essayé de
voir un schéma ? Est-ce que tu as essayé
de recouper ça avec une sisigie de
certaines planètes ?
Mais mais non mais je recoupe avec rien
du tout. Je fais des maths. Non, tout
d'un coup, je me regarde par exemple là,
j'étais
Est-ce que tu as déjà essayé
d'enregistrer la conversation ?
Non. Non, parce que j'ai pas les moyens
techniques. Je me rappelle un jour
Fariol l'avait fait et il avait une
petite cassette là-dessus. C'est assez
rigolo. Euh donc il me passe sa
cassette. On l'a tellement écouté, je
crois qu'il y a il y a des gens sur
internet qui l' qui Mais c'est quasiment
inaudible. Et l'histoire est assez
marrante. Il y a un bonhomme qui
travaille pour la banque Rotfield à
Madrid qui rentre en voiture la nuit et
tout d'un coup il s'arrête parce que il
y a une soucoupe qui est sur le bord de
la route et à ce moment-là il a le
réflexe de prendre sa trousse à outil en
disant est-ce que vous avez besoin
d'aide ? Carrément [rires]
c'est surréaliste. Alors il tombe sur
des types qui ont ressemblent à des
humains et il dit mais vous ressemblez à
des humains ? Mais on est des humains.
Ah bon ? Oui oui, on est les descendants
d'humain qui ont été emmenés et alors
l'autre dit mais vous avez pas songé à
vous évader évader pour revenir sur
cette planète. Vous rigolez vous voyez
déjà bon. Alors après il revient à
Madrid, il raconte ça à sa femme. Le
truc se propage un petit peu et à ce
moment-là les autres extraterrestres
téléphonent en disant on aimerait vous
rencontrer. Et à ce moment-là la chose
s'est propagée et en fait dans
l'appartement du type c'était un
véritable guetapan. Il y avait Fariols
avec ses trucs d'enregistrement, enfin
et le téléphone sonne et Fariol
enregistre et on entend euh nos formouen
prononas ne
que que les euh
preguntas
renous
que les gens réunis dans ce dessus
missile ne posent pas de questions. Nous
sommes désolés, nous allons couper la
communication. Donc il y a ces quelques
phrases qui sont enregistrées et moi
simplement c'est la rare fois où je suis
revenu avec l'enregistrement et je l'ai
fait analyser par le laboratoire de
phonétique de d'ex et alors la réponse
c'est que c'était pas une voix humaine.
Alors évidemment on pourrait dire oui
bien sûr ça a été fait parci par ça mais
ce qui est assez intéressant c'est que
ces gens-là prétendent qu'il ils
formulent les sons avec des replis
farragés. Ils ont pas de corde vocale.
Donc à ce moment-là, la richesse
phonique est beaucoup plus faible. Et en
particulier, ça s'appelle du rectotonau.
Nous quand on fait une voyelle, on a des
notre système est instable. Quand vous
faites ah ça se balade comme ça alors
qu'avec des repliragés plus rigides la
production sonore sera différente.
Voilà, c'est un petit détail à chaque
fois dès qu'on tire un fil mais j'ai pas
cherché à aller beaucoup plus loin et
tout ça. Non, ce qui est important c'est
le questionnement philosophique d'un
truc pareil hein. Quel peu importe ce
coup de téléphone, est-ce que le type
avait une voix comme ceci, comme cela,
est-ce que j'ai Non, mais qu'est-ce que
ça modifie ? C'est extraordinaire. Ça
donne une prise sur la métaphysique sur
la structure de l'univers. En ce moment,
toujours à partir de ces informations,
je [grognement] me suis lancé dans une
entreprise complètement mirobolante
d'essayer de géométriser la mécanique
quantique. Ça ça a l'air de commencer à
marcher. C'est extraordinaire. Non mais
j'ai une vie passionnante. C'est pour ça
il y a des gens qui disent "Mais comment
vous faites pour ne pas vieillir ?" Moi
je réponds j'ai pas le temps. Je suis
tellement passionné, je veux pas manquer
la suite de l'histoire. Al, qu'est-ce
qui va se passer pour ce qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont raconter le prochain coup ?
[rires]
Les gens Les gens qui te critiquent
quoi
les gens qui te critiquent les gens qui
qui essayent te de te faire passer pour
un douinzin
ou
tu les regardes comment ? Tu as envie de
leur répondre quoi ou ça ça t'indiffère
au plus haut point ?
Bah le drame c'est que ça ça ferme les
maisons d'édition, ça ferme les médias,
ça ferme des tas de choses. Voilà, c'est
comme ça. Et donc je suis quand même
suivi par des gens qui savent que je
suis pas complètement barge. En
particulier quand même, faut dire la
chose suivante, c'est que [grognement]
tout se sent ce petit
académicien là d'amour. Mais ça date de
7 ans. Mais en 7 ans, j'ai fait une
publication de 24 pages dans une revue
European Physical Journal C
Janus.
Sur Janus, j'ai fait les bases
mathématiques dans le journal de
physique mathématique. J'ai fait euh un
un papier sur les galaxies dans
Astrophysic on Space Science. J'ai fait
le papier sur les plug star et je viens
de faire deux autres papiers. Ça fait
sep articles, hein. Il y a une chose que
était relu
dans des revues de haut niveau à chaque
fois. Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est
que ce je reste complètement, vous savez
la science,
il faut marquer les buts sur le terrain,
faut pas parler dans les vestières et
actuellement quand on dit ce que vous
croyez ça c'est des bar c'est c'est
c'est du bavardage de vestiaire. Non non
et même quand on dit est-ce qu'il y a
des gens qui vous critiquent ? Moi, je
les mets au défi de me critiquer dans
une revue à comité de lecture. Mais
c'est important. Est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte de là où on en est
actuellement ? La cosmologie est en
crise, ça se sait. Bon,
comment ça se passe déjà ? Moi, on va
faire un petit retour là-dessus
rapidement.
C'est né quand ? Un truc comme ça ?
Enfin, c'est né en 1900, hein. Et alors
même
rapidement, on pourrait dire mais il y a
une époque qui est vertigineuse 1850
1950, voilà un siècle. Pendant un siècle
notre science est bouleversée un point
qu' on ne se souvient même plus. Il y
avait pas d'équation avant. Il y avait
pas d'équation en 1850. Les équations de
Maxwell, c'est 1860. Les équations de
navier stock, c'est même époque. On tout
d'un coup, on a des équations qui nous
permettent d'avoir pris sur les objets,
d'avoir des modèles. Et alors, vous avez
un personnage qui est Lor El Kelvin, un
anglais qui avait été annobli par la
reine. Il a un discours mémorable en
1900 en disant voilà avec ces équations,
on a une maîtrise complète sur
l'univers. Il y a plus qu'à calculer
pour trouver les chiffres après la
virgule. Mais c'est vrai, c'est
extraordinaire. Et il dit ça en 1900
alors qu'on sait que euh en 1905 il y a
la relativité restreinte et 1915
relativité générale, ça va de nouveau
basculer. Donc pendant ce siècle, non
seulement on a eu les équations qui
apparaissent qui est quand même un
apport considérable, on a aussi on s'est
donné aussi des moyens d'observation.
Rappelez-vous, c'est aussi au 19e siècle
que la spectroscopie apparaît, hein,
avec Fronfer l'allemand, avec Bonsen, on
s'aperçoit que quand on chauffe un truc
et qu'on regarde avec un pris, on peut
dire "Ah, c'était le matériaux." Et
alors un truc comme ça, ça a permis de
savoir de quel matériaux étaient faites
les étoiles. Vous vous rendez compte ?
C'est extraordinaire. Ensuite, il y a un
truc merveilleux, c'est l'effet de
plaire. Alors encore euh je me rappelle
il y a une vingtaine d'années, il y
avait une Micheline qui passait avec son
Provence et il y avait un passage à
niveau. Alors on la on l'entendait
claxonner, elle faisait mais bon ça
c'est l'effet de plaire. Le son est plus
haut quand il se rapproche, c'est plus
bas. Et alors ce qui est assez marrant
c'est que l'effet de a été prévu par
doir et il y a quelqu'un qui a voulu le
vérifier. C'est un suédois qui s'appelle
Buibalo. Et comment est-ce qu'on a
vérifié le fait de plaire ? avec un
train à vapeur avec une locomotive qui
30 à l'heure et à ce moment-là on a mis
sur une plateforme un orchestre et les
gens jouaient et les ceux qui étaient
restés sur le c ont pu constater que le
son était plus élevé quand il se
rapprochait plus bas. Voilà, on a
vérifié l'effet de pl C'est mignon comme
tout.
Il était rouge ou bleu le son ? [rires]
Non non mais le truc après c'est donc
tu as compris la tu as compris la
blague.
Ouais mais mais on peut on a pu mesurer
les vitesses, on a pu constater que l'un
est en expansion. Enfin tout ça 1850
1950 il y a un bouleversement
scientifique
absolument extraordinaire. Puis dans la
prière ça s'arrête ça s'arrête. Euh il y
a quelques euh quelques escarbilles
comme ça, quelques petites dernières euh
on invente les quarqu. Bon ça ça
fonctionne. Et puis tout d'un coup, on a
vu une chose par exemple en physique des
particules, les théoriciens disent il
doit y avoir des super particules, hein,
le neutralino, le photonino, le
gravitino et cetera et ça marche pas. La
nature ne répond pas. La nature ne
refuse de coopérer. On prédit les
choses, ça marche pas. Voilà. Après vous
avez un autre truc, c'est la théorie des
cordes. On se tape 30 ans de théorie des
cordes, bilan que dalle, rien. Alors
ensuite l'astrophysique. Alors
l'astrophysique c'est extraordinaire.
Tout d'un coup euh euh Hubble s'aperçoit
que les galaxies nous fuient. Ensuite il
y a Friedman le russe qui qui fait
sortir ça de l'équation d'Instein. Alors
ce qui est merveilleux, c'est que
Friedman a sorti ce résultat
extraordinaire. Et après, qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait ? Oh ben, il s'est orienté
vers la météo. Faut pas croire que les
gens ont des carrières comme ça, ils
vont continuer. Bon, alors après bon,
on remonte l'histoire de l'univers dans
le passé et puis les gens se disent
"Bah, il y a un moment où l'univers
était très chaud, il s'est passé quelque
chose." Bon, alors s'il était très
chaud, il y a un moment où il était fait
de matière et d'antimatière. Et
l'antimatière, c'est monsieur d'Irac qui
prédit ça avec ses équations. Tout d'un
coup, il tourne la la cuillère dans la
marmite, il dit "Ah, il doit y avoir des
électrons positifs." Et alors là, c'est
assez amusant, c'est que lorsque les
gens amènent des idées neuves comme ça,
c'est pas accueilli forcément dans
l'enthousiasme. Et Nilsbor
Nilsbor lui dit
"Oh la théorie d'Irac, ça doit être un
bon truc pour capturer les éléphants."
Comment capturer les éléphants ? Oui,
vous prenez un arbre en fin d'Afrique,
vous accrochez la toride d'Irak, un
éléphant arrive, il lit, il est
tellement surpris que vous pouvez le
capturer sans difficulté. Voilà, donc il
faisait de l'humour mais d'Irak prédit
ça, on observe. Alors en plus avec les
calculs en remontant l'univers dans le
passé, il y a une époque où il était
fait de matière et d'antimatière, il y a
eu une anhilation et il doit rester des
photons de cette anhilation et on les
trouve en 67. Alors en 67, le modèle du
Big Bang commence à à prendre du corps.
Donc on arrive à ces années 770 puis
après ça s'arrête. Alors ça s'arrête,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Quand est-ce
que ça se met à dérailler exactement ?
Parce que c'est vraiment tout d'un coup
cette espèce de belle mécanique s'est
mis à ne plus marcher. Bon et bien euh
ça a commencé par les la vitesse de
rotation dans les galaxies. Moi, je je
suis rentré à l'observatoire de
Marseille aux environs de 1964, un truc
comme ça, 63 64 et à l'époque
effectivement on faisait des mesures de
vitesse mais c'était très imprécis. Il a
fallu attendre 70 pour qu'on commence à
avoir des des mesures. Donc à ce
moment-là, on a une courbe de vitesse.
Au lieu de décroître, il y a une
survitesse en périphérie. Bon,
[grognement] ça et à ce moment-là euh la
la matière qui se trouvait dans les
galaxies ne suffisait plus. Alors, on a
inventé la matière sombre. On a inventé
la matière son et alors on arrive
justement à cette ce mode de
raisonnement quand même qui est assez
étonnant. Euh la méterion existe
puisqu'on a cet effet. Voilà. Alors moi
je je sais pas mais rappelez-vous une
chose, c'est que euh
c'est au 19e siècle qu'on qu'on mesurait
l'avance du périline de Mercure. La
planète Mercure, elle a une trajectoire
elliptique mais son ellipse a tendance à
tourner comme ça. Bon et bien la
première explication fournie, c'est
c'est
que les noms propres c'est difficile
quand on vieillit hein. [rires]
Tu as 24 ans, tu déconnes.
Oui. Alors
euh oh je me rappelle le bonhomme mais
il a prédit que c'était dû à une planète
qu'il appelait Vulquin et on l'a pas
observé et aujourd'hui on dirait on
l'observe pas parce que c'est une
planète noire sans blague pourquoi pas
hein et alors donc là on crée cette
matière noire et on est on continue à la
chercher alors que le modèle Génus dit
laissez tomber c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche. Alors après donc après la
matière noire ça se complique encore. On
voit que l'univers au lieu de se
ralentirer, il accélère. Comme il
accélère, on invente la l'énergie noire.
Donc on a des rustines hein. Le modèle
standard est couvert de rustine. Alors
si
si si tes si tes collègues adoptent ton
modèle ou du moins le reconnaissent,
c'est ça a quelle implication ?
Bah c'est catastrophique. Mais tout leur
tous leurs travaux se cassent la gueule.
Disons que quand Einstein invente la
relativité générale, il ne dit pas
"Monsieur Newton est un con, hein." Non,
Newton a raison. Moi simplement, il y a
des petites des petites différences
infimes. Tandis que c'est pas des
différences infimes. Vous prenez tous
vos travaux sur la matière noire, vous
jetez. Tous vos travaux sur l'énergie
noire, vous jetez.
Et mais l'inflation aussi. Voilà.
Modèle Janus, bah c'est le papier de
1988 que j'ai fait. Mais voilà, je veux
dire que comment est-ce que je pourrais
être reçu dans une dans une un monde où
où je je casse tout quoi. J'ai
l'impression d'être un éléphant dans un
magasin de porcelaine. Dès que je bouge,
il y a un truc qui tombe. Alors, par
exemple, il y a une chose, c'est vrai
qu' a un moment, je me suis dit, c'est
pas mal. Vous savez, on dit la défense
c'est la l'attaque c'est la meilleure
défense. J'ai pas fait ça si malument
pour ça, mais je me suis offert deux
papiers,
40 pages et 55 pages. Ça fait 95 pages.
Le titre, c'est le modèle incohérence
mathématique et géométrique du modèle du
trou noir. C'est pas mal. Et le modèle
du trou noir, c'est une chimère. Ça
tient pas debout. C'est catastrophique.
Alors dans un truc comme ça, il faut
chercher une image pour que ça parle aux
gens. Alors on pourrait [grognement]
dire mais qu'est-ce que c'est le
comportement général du scientifique ?
Bah imaginez que le monde soit un
château. Alors c'est un château. Donc
vous allez explorer une pièce et puis
avec un moyen observationnel vous allez
explorer la pièce suivante. Vous allez
chercher puis alors on prend des notes
pour avoir le plan du château, pour
avoir une idée de savoir comment il est
fait. tout d'un coup, il y a quelqu'un
qui a un truc qui dit "Vous, j'ai trouvé
un escalier qui descend au sous-sol et à
ce momentlà, on va explorer le sous-sol
et le sous-sol, il est vastissime
simplement il est on n plus dans le
château, on est dans des dans des
galeries qui vont complètement en
dehors. Vous savez comme les catacombes
quoi. C'est c'est effant. Et là euh euh
le l'escalier, il est au centre du trou
noir. C'est-à-dire que quand on prend
cette solution géométrique, il y a
l'extérieur de l'objet et tout d'un
coup, hop, quand on rentre à l'intérieur
de l'objet, on pénètre dans le monde
imaginaire. On n plus dans le réel, on
n'est plus dans la physique. Donc c'est
ce que j'explique dans cet article là.
et bon sang euh j'aimerais présenter ça
en séminaire mais chez des
mathématiciens, des géomètres chez des
physi n'importe qui j'arrive en courant
les portes sont fermées. Alors le truc
c'est très simple depuis des années,
j'envoie mes travaux imprimés avec des
lettres en disant voilà j'aimerais
présenter ça en séminaire. On ne me
répond pas, on ne répond pas à
Jean-Pierre Petit et c'est peut-être
parce que je dérange mais aussi il y a
l'affaire Dominguez hein. Est-ce que
vous vous rendez compte de que ça
représente un truc pareil ? Ils se
disent il va nous parler de ça une
catastrophe parce que ça c'est
Dominguez c'était coup de fil de la nuit
c'est ça ? Oui, mais oui. Le bonhomme
qui en 88 dit quand une étoile à neutron
est déstabilisée, elle expédie la
matière en jumeau dans dans
excès dans le jumeau. C'est énorme entre
pareil, c'est énorme parce que ça pose
un problème. Soit alors monsieur Domigez
est en contact avec un avec je ne sais
pas le le la mémoire générale de du
cosmos, hein. Soit alors soit alors il y
a vraiment un bonhomme au téléphone qui
vient d'une autre planète. Ce qu'il
raconte c'est vrai. Donc autrement dit
il y aurait des visiteurs et en plus il
communiquent avec nous
et en plus il nous téléphone
[rires]
avec un numéro privé ou un numéro
masqué. Comment ça se passe ?
Mais non
non mais le truc c'est que ils appellent
la nuit. Moi je pense c'est parce que
c'est leurs leurs heures de bureau parce
que moi ce que j'ai pu comprendre
à l'anglais
quoi.
C'est leurs ordres de bureau à
l'anglais.
Non non non non non non.
Le le truc c'est que
euh prenons par exemple les petits gris
hein. Les petits gris ont ils ont des
grands yeux noirs. Bon un jour il y a un
témoin qui a pu voir les yeux derrière
les yeux. En fait ils ont pas les yeux
noirs, ils ont des verrs qui foncent à
la lumière. Et simplement, c'est ce que
auraient des gens qui sont nicktalope.
Nicktalope, c'est-à-dire qu' ils vivent
la nuit et ils craignent le jour. Voilà,
pigé. Donc à ce moment-là, bon bah 3h du
matin, c'est les heures de bureau pour
eux. Le jour, ils dorment. Voilà.
Tu penses qu'ils ont encore des bureaux
?
Je sais pas, mais moi il faut avoir un
peu d'humour, un truc comme sans blague
ce sujet-là. Si on n pas un peu d'humour
déjà, moi je raconter une histoire que
j'aime bien. Donc dans des histoires
comme ça, il y a des messages qui
arrivent par-ci par téléphone, par email
aussi, des choses comme ça. Bon et un
moment, il y a des années,
on recevait des messages codés et à ce
moment-là, c'était des lettres et tout
ça. Et alors, il y avait il nous avaient
filé un programme qu'on mettait dans un
ordinateur et on faisait un coupécollé
des des 0 et des 1 dans la case objet.
Il y avait toute une suite de 0 et des
1. En mettant ça, c'était la la clé qui
permettait de lire. Alors à ce
moment-là, un message, deux messages,
mais c'était assez emmerdant quoi. Bon à
vous venez certain temps, j'ai laissé
tomber. Puis un an plus tard, tout d'un
coup, je reçois de nouveau un message
codé comme ça. Je sais pas. Alors j'ai
répondu et ta sœur ?
Et à ce momentlà le message, tu
avais rechiffré dans l'autre sens pour
répondre à ta sœur ou pas ?
Non. Non, mais je reçois un message codé
de gens qui veulent encore m'emmerder
pour que je fasse marcher un programme
d'ordinateur pour écouter leurs
conneries, quoi. Donc, je réponds et ta
sœur ? Et j'ai la réponse que j'obtiens,
c'est nous sommes extrêmement étonnés de
notre autre réponse car à notre
connaissance aucune de nos sœurs n'est
contact avec vous. Mais la soupe au
chou, c'est rien à côté. Voilà. Voilà.
Mais moi, je pense un jour avec mon ami
pasteur, on était à Digne et euh il y
avait eu un atterrissage d'ovis à tel
endroit et à ce moment-là, on arrive sur
les lieux et il y avait un paysan quoi.
Et euh quand on parle de ça, le paysan
explique que il a été témoin. Oui, j'ai
tout vu. J'ai tout vu même quand le
grand il engueulait les deux petits.
[rires] Alors ce on lui dit "Mais vous
avez pas songé à témoigner ?" Voilà la
phrase du paysan. Vous savez là-bas
c'est pas mon champ. Ils invitent qui
ils veulent.
Voilà, il y a il y a un port
humoristique dans ce dossier là qui est
absolument extraordinaire. Le
le mec t'avait contacté en direct ou pas
du tout, tu étais arrivé comment ?
Le mec qui le cutéreux, le paysan qui
t'a appelé à côté. Nous, on était venu
avec pasteur et le paysan était là. Puis
quand on lui parle de ça, vous avez
entendu parler de ce qui s'est passé ?
Oui même que j'étais là quand le grand
il engueulait les deux petits mais il
s'en foutait lui tout voilà
il t'a fait une description qu'est-ce
qu'il t'a raconté il était gr
mais ça l'intéressait pas c'est un
paysan mais ce quiéresse
c'est les récoltes c'est la météo les
extraterrest rien à moi je pense
à un truc un jour je suis allé à Digne
et à la gendarmerie j'étais reçu par un
haut gradé de la gendarmerie et ce type
dit moi-mère
est de la région et elle habite dans un
endroit complètement perdu. Et un jour,
la grand-mère lui raconte qu'il y a un
truc qui s'est posé dans dans son
potager avec des petits bons hommes qui
sont sortis, hein. Et elle elle lui a
elle lui dit "J'ai pris un bateau en
disant "Vous allez faire les cons
ailleurs que dans mon potager." Mais
c'est important. Les extraterrestres
sont fou. C'est qu'ils ont abîmé ces
salades. Voilà, c'est [rires] tout.
Tu as fait des relevés sur place ? Tu
étais venu pour constater ?
Non, j'ai pas fait de relev mais quand
on prend l'histoire de Trans en
Provence, Bunas l'a fait. Je veux dire,
il y a une chose, c'est que un type
comme Buas, il lui a cassé sa carrière.
Moi, Bunia, c'était un type qui avait un
un un labo, il faisait des recherches
très intéressantes et on l'a puni, on
l'a puni. Ses collaborateurs, on leur
offert une promotion en échange qu'il du
fait qu'il le quitte. Après, on lui a
pris ses locaux, il s'est retrouvé tout
seul dans un bureau à la facunion. Il a
été puni. Mais moi, j'étais déjà puni.
On pourrait dire "Mais Jean-Pierre
Petit, il faudrait lui enlever ses
crédits, il a pas de crédit. Alors,
enlevez-vous son matériel, il a pas de
matériel." [rires]
Voilà.
Pourquoi on punit les gens comme ça ?
Mais parce que s'intéresser à ça,
il faut punir les gens par qui le
scandalur à ceux par qui le scandale
arrive. Voilà, c'est dans la Bible.
Mais c'est scandaleux quoi, c'est tout.
C'est pour ça que on neutralise, pour ça
qu'on discrédite parce queil y a un
scandale qui arrive. Jean-Pierre,
j'en sais rien mais est-ce que j'étais
discrétisé ? Mais je m'en fous. Par
exemple des gens, regarde quand on avait
eu c cette ia au téléphone qui qui
parlait du fait que j'étais discrédité,
mais par qui nom de Dieu ? Pour être
discrédité, c'est dans l'article dans
une revue scientifique. Moi, j'ai
demandé à monsieur d'amour publier
quelque chose en une revue. Que dal.
J'ai jamais pu le rencontrer. Il ne
répond à rien. J'ai demandé un droit de
réponse à l'équi que dalle. Tu
as essayé de faire son réseau. Par
exemple, nous quand il y a des gens qui
essayent de nous discréditer,
on fait comme toi, on fait le don, on
écoute, on regarde et puis on essaie de
voir dans quel réseau, il quel réseau il
fonctionne, qui les finance, où est-ce
qu'ils vont faire leur colloques, qui
est-ce qu'il rencontre, dans quel
quartier, quels échanges ils peuvent
avoir avec les gens qu'on a déjà spoté.
Tu as pas essayé de savoir si c'était
pas, je vais pas dire un complot, mais
que les États-Unis et essayé de te faire
passer pour un doux rêveur pour éviter
que le la France et le général de Gaulle
s'empare de ça parce que on avait
l'équivalent de notre Trinstein avec
Jean-Pierre Petit. [rires]
Oui, mais jamais pensé à ça. Le truc
essayé de faire un dossier pour faire
triste. Le truc qui me manque triste,
c'est que avec tous ces travaux là, la
France pourrait être en pointe. On est
vraiment dans la mé
d'industrie, on a plus de commerce, on
est dirigé par des crétins. C'est quand
même effant. On pourrait être en pointe,
en pôle position et à cause de la quarte
ronde d'académicien, il bloque tout
quoi. C'est fou. Mais qu'est-ce que je
peux rien y faire.
Donc on est condamné
quoi ?
On est condamné.
On est condamné à quoi ?
À la guerre.
Ah oui, ça c'est extraordinaire.
Le chef d'étatmajor
de de Macron a déclaré que dans 3 ans on
serait en guerre contre les Russes.
Il y a pas que lui he il y a le chef
d'état-major anglais aussi.
Oh là là là ! Mais mais qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire ? Je sais pas, on sait plus
quoi faire.
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on appelle tes
copains au téléphone à 3h du matin ?
Tu penses que si on va à la 3e guerre
mondiale,
on aura des OVNIS qui vont se manifester
pour s'interposer ? Ils vont nous
regarder comme des des des tribus
sauvages s'entretuer ?
Bah il y a un truc à chaque fois, c'est
que moi euh pendant des années, il se
trouve que je me suis occupé de Safari
ou Kenya. Donc
photo photo
non photo oui on avait j'avais une lande
rever avec des pingouins qui étaient et
qui prenait des photos puis à un moment
je vois une gazelle avec un guépard.
Tu parles Swili
quoi ?
Tu parles Swili ?
Oh il y a longtemps.
C'est vrai
Diambo. Diabo. [rires]
Voilà. Et Kiboko l'hippotame. Voilà.
Et euh donc tout le monde voit la
le guépard qui va sauter sur la gazelle
à ce moment. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On
prévient la gazelle. Je veux dire que si
on regarde la Terre, qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? On a des une évolution
conflictuelle avec c'est pas un cas. Il
y a une imbécilité généralisée, quoi.
C'est quelque chose d'effrayant.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire ? En
plus, si on on révèle aux gens que
voilà. Alors, disons que j'ai commencé à
recevoir des lettres dans les années 90.
Voilà. Euh oui, bien sûr. Et après cette
histoire de d'or
mais oui. Alors, les gens me disent
"Vous avez gardé les lettres ?" Mais
non, j'ai rien gardé du tout. Ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est ce qu'il y a dedans,
quoi. Voilà. Et à un moment, il y avait
une sorte de protocole. Voilà ce que
nous prévoyons pour le contact avec un
contact généralisé en 2050. Je dis "Mais
ça marchera jamais. Vous n'imaginez pas
les mécanismes immunologiques,
sociologiques. Euh la pour les terriens,
le fait de se considérer comme le centre
du monde, c'est absolument
indispensable. Tout d'un coup, si
vraiment il y a d'autres gens, mais
est-ce qu'on n'est pas les Moi, il y a
un truc qui m'amuse assez euh je me
considère comme un hamster. Je suis un
gentil hamster. Voilà. Et [grognement]
il y a des gens qui en savent infiniment
plus que moi. Des gens qui de temps en
temps me me fil une petite pichenette de
d'information comme ça. Tiens, on va lui
filer ça, on va voir ce qu'il va en
faire. C'est assez marrant mais quand
même je suis fier d'être un hamster.
[rires]
Voilà. Et je trouve que nous devrions en
tant que terrien
prendre conscience de notre personnalité
de hamster. On a on a des choses quand
même étonnantes. On a inventé la
musique. Ils disent que la musique ça
existe pas ailleurs. C'est
extraordinaire. L'art n'existe pas.
C'est vrai que si on a 500
ethnies différentes avec 500 cultures,
c'est un une richesse culturelle
hallucinante.
Des gens qui vivent la nuit, ils savent
pas ce qui est beau et ce qui est lait.
Vous comprenez ?
Nous, on a la musique, on a la peinture.
Quand ils reviennent de la terre, ils
disent, "Vous savez, ils ont une chose,
c'est que ils font des sons et alors ils
ont une façon de jouer avec les
fréquences.
C'est très sophistiqué. On y comprend
rien.
Comment tu sais ça ?
Mais ils l'écrivent dans de Dieu. Ils le
disent bien sûr.
Ils te le disent à toi.
Mais par mais
mais [rires]
ça traîne dans tous les textes. Enfin
bon sang de bois. Mais voilà, on est euh
euh on est comme une un zoau quoi. Et
euh on est observé par des gens qui
trouvent que c'est dommage qu'on foute
parce que il y a une chose, c'est que
nous on se voit comme au centre de la
planète mais on est une espèce parmi la
toutes les planètes. La la Terre c'est
un c'est un une richesse biologique
considérable sur le plan animal végétal.
C'est extraordinaire. On est en train de
tout en l'air. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? Vous me parlez de des guerres,
est-ce qu'ils vont intervenir ? Mais
simplement, il y a c Qu'est-ce qu'on
s'emmerde avec ces bipèdes
polychrome là qui qui s'apprête encore
une fois de se sur la gueule
vraiment. Ah bon ? Mais ils ont pas
encore compris ? Non, ils ont pas encore
compris. Alors où ça se passe ? Bah ça
se passe en Iran. En Iran ? Mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe encore ? Ah oui !
Et alors en plus c'est merveilleux parce
que il lance une guerre et quand ils
réfléchissent ils savent même pas
pourquoi. Ça c'est génial. La première
fois que on se lance dans une opération
de guerre sans savoir pourquoi. Voilà.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Tu sais tu sais pourquoi ils sont lancés
?
Tu le sais ?
Bah bien sûr. C'est pour faire plaisir à
c'est apporter la démocratie pour les
petites filles. Bien sûr. Bien sûr.
C'est c'est apporter la civilisation.
Bien sûr. Et et c'est et c'est
tu le sais comme moi c'est c'est une
question de ressources, de sécurisation
de zone d'influence.
C'est une question je fais une petite un
gros croche-pied à mon copain chinois
comme ça je garde mon hégémonie et j'en
passe des meilleurs ce qu'on te raconte
au journal de 20h sur tout ça. Bon quand
tu creuses un peu, tu vois que il y a
toujours des questions d'énergie. Mais
ce qu'on voit maintenant, c'est les
comment dire la crise dans l'empire
américain, la crise du dollar, c'est
central un truc pareil. Dès que des gens
ont voulu toucher un dollar, dès que
Saddam Husen a voulu surpayer son
pétrole en autre chose que le dollar,
mais il s'est ramassé
Kadfi, je pense aussi non ? Kaddafi
aussi elle vou
aussi en Libye bien sûr, bien sûr, bien
sûr. Et là, il faut comprendre ces
choses-là mais actuellement il y a un
truc assez intéressant, c'est que Trump
a voulu bloquer l'entrée des troismuses,
mais il y a des pétroliers chinois qui
sont sortis, il a pas osé, il les a
raisonné.
Mais là, je sais pas avec quoi on joue
mais c'est c'est énorme qu un truc
pareil. Mais surtout mais la France mais
c'est à moi j'aime bien cette expression
c'est à se poignarder le cul avec des
saucisses vraiment. Non mais c'est
des saucisses congelées ou
non mais quand on voit Non mais quand on
voit ce qui se passe quand on voit quand
on voit nos médias qui sont tous entre
les mains des buisseurs d'argent c'est
incroyable.
C'est une lipe que tu as au poignet
quoi.
C'est une lipe ta montre ? Bon, c'est
une monte de comme favore.
Ah merde ! Non non non, rien
d'extraordinaire. Non, mais
actuellement, on se dit mais comment ça
va tourner nom de Dieu ? Est-ce que les
Israéliens vont utiliser la bombe
atomique par exemple ? Voilà hein.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tes amis qui
t'appellent à 3h du matin, ils vont les
laisser faire ?
Ils ont quoi ?
Est-ce qu'ils vont les empêcher ? J'en
sais rien moi. J'en sais rien. Je ne
suis qu'un hamster. [rires] Je ne suis
que l'hamster de service.
Si toi tu es un hamster, les autres
c'est des protoser quand même hein.
Ouais.
Et tu dis oui en plus tu es vilain.
[rires] Tu es vraiment vilain. Revenons
à notre sujet.
Là, il y a une accélération quand même
de contenu. Il y a une accélération de
contenu issu de militaire expertisé et
déclassifié par le pouvoir politique.
Toi, ça te fait penser à quoi ? Tu
penses que va y avoir une déclation ? Je
le redis, tout ce qui se passe en
Amérique, c'est de la gesticulation,
hein. On peut faire des auditions au
Sénat américain, des gens qui viennent
témoigner. À chaque fois, les gens sont
là. Je me rappelle pour Cométais on est
en train de nous préparer à quelque
chose. On nous prépare à rien du tout.
C'est c'est des flops, des choses comme
ça, c'est tout. Et quand même le dans
les fameuses auditions aux États-Unis,
dans les fameuses auditions aux
États-Unis, ils disent voilà, euh il y a
des militaires qui auraient récupéré des
corps. Ils ont fait des paroles. C'est
des paroles. Où sont les Où sont ?
Alors,
ils ont fait de la rétroingénierie.
Un autre dossier là, ça va vous plaire.
Disons que euh moi j'ai un côté
s'aventurier. Je veux dire toi aussi
d'ailleurs. Je veux dire [grognement]
que quelque fois quand on pose quelque
chose, moi je dis pas non. Donc il y a 2
ans, un type qui s'appelle Thierry Jamin
qui est au Pérou me dit "Est-ce que vous
seriez prêt à faire une expédition au
Pérou ?" OK, alors je prends mon épouse
qui est toujours prête. Nous partons
tous les deux au Pérou avec d'autres
Français. Et alors pour éviter d'être
identifié par les populations locales,
il a fallu qu'on traverse la cordilière
des en voiture, ce qui est assez
fatiguant quoi. Et
pris de la coca.
Non non, on n pas eu le temps de des
choses comme ça. Mais simplement ce qui
se passe que Thierry Jamin, c'est un peu
le Indiana Jones français mais il est
très gentil quoi.
Connaî pas. Euh ben il a fait beaucoup
d'expéditions pour trouver des vies dans
oubliées dans dans parce que quand on
prend le Pérou au nord-est, c'est
l'Amazonnie quoi. Bon, il y a fait des
choses de ce genre-là. Puis [grognement]
alors il y a une dizaine d'années, il y
a un type qui prend contact avec lui
parce que il y a une chose au Pérou,
c'est que la le trafic des antiquités,
c'est une une industrie nationale. Par
exemple, une momie euh ça vaut 50000
dollars si tu l'achètes prêt à
l'emmener. Si après il faut le sortir du
Pérou, ça coûte plus cher parce qu'il
faut payer des gens. Mais il y a presque
un tarif quoi. Vous voulez ceci, vous
voulez cela. Donc ces gens-là, on les
appelle les wascos quoi, les les gens
qui font ce genre de trafic. Et tout
d'un coup, il y a ces gens-là, ils
tombent sur un oser, sur un
comment dire sur un une véritable ville
souterraine avec des mouis. Et il y a
une chose, c'est que en Égypte, on quand
on veut momifier les gens, on prend les
corps et on les met dans un un carbonate
de calcium qui s'appelle le natron. Et
le natron estoscopique, il va prendre
l'humidité, hein. Bon, à ce moment-là,
les les bons hommes sont tout noirates
comme ça. Ils sont prêts à être mis dans
leur bandelettes et tout. Et euh en
Pérou, ils ont des gisements de à chaque
fois le nom m'échappe. Les squelettes de
du plancton
de la terre de euh squelettes de
Plankon.
Ça commence par un N. Non.
Oui, comme ça.
Ça va me revenir. Continue.
Voilà. Bon, il y a même un un gisement.
On l'a visité, il fait 10 ou 20 m
d'épaisseur. Donc c'est une époque où
c'est c'est ces minuscules squelettes de
plancton sont déposés. Et alors
l'industrie pharma
diatomé
diatomé diatomé diatomé et on utilise
diatomé en pharmacie pour deux choses.
D'abord effectivement ça prend
l'humidité mais aussi c'est
antiseptique.
Donc autrement dit quand on a voulu
modifier des corps au Pérou on les a mis
dans des diatomées. Donc à ce momentlà
ce que c'estes euh [gémissement]
Waskeros découvrent dans ses
souterrains, ce sont des cuves dans
lequel il y a des corps qui sont dans
les diatomées. Alors si quand on les
ressort comme les diatomés s'attachent
un peu au corps, on a l'impression
qu'ils sont recouverts de plâtre quoi et
cetera. Alors le problème c'est que si
c'est des décors humains, il y a pas de
problème, il pourrait les vendre. Mais
là ce qui sortent c'est quand même des
trucs bizarres. Il y en a qui sont
grands comme ça, ils ont trois doigts
aux mains et trois trois orteils au pied
et cetera. Donc ça ressemble à des faux
comme c'est pas possible comment vendre
un truc pareil quoi. Donc c'est vraiment
des c'est pas des corps humains. Et à
ce-là, il montre ça à Thierry Jamin et
euh Jamin qui euh qui venait d'hériter
de son père achète des momies de ce
genre. Donc il a acheté plusieurs corps
de ce genre et il a dépensé de l'argent
pour faire analyser l'ADN, pour faire
analyser le carbone 14 et cetera. Alors,
au carbone 14, les corps datent du 13e
siècle ou chose comme ça. Et là où c'est
intéressant, c'est l'analyse ADN parce
que nous, on a 95 % d'ADN en commun avec
le chapanzé. Là, c'est seulement euh 30
% humain. Donc déjà, c'est très
exotique. Alors
ça, ça a été ça a été triangulé,
ressourcé, expertisé.
Bah, il y a il y a eu des émissions qui
ont été faites là-dessus. Il y a eu des
bouquins bouquin qui a été fait
là-dessus. Il y a
il y a eu des organismes scientifiques
reconnus qui se sont penchés qu' ont
expertisé la chose ou c'est un hax c'est
un canular.
C'est pas un cané de poser la question.
C'est pas un canular. C'est pas un
canular. Les gens qui ont analyse mais
il est certain que les gens qui ne
veulent pas que ça sorte vont dire que
ce sont des faux. C'est tout.
Si si tu interroges n'importe quel même,
il te dira "Oui, mais ce truc là, on a
montré que c'était fait avec des crânes
de lama par exemple et puis on a montré
que ceci, on a montré que cela." Oui,
mais comment on fait pour que ce soit du
13e siècle ? Comment on fait pour qu'il
y ait 30 % d'é humain et cetera ? Il y a
quand bon mais
si c'est des crânes de lama, facile.
Mais oui, mais mais voilà un sujet qui
dérange et il dérange au point que c'est
le rejet total. Mais le rejet total non
seulement chez les scientifiques mais
chez les ceux qui s'intituent
l'uphologue aussi. C'est pareil. Alors
le truc c'est que quand je suis allé au
Pérou, j'ai pas vu une momie, j'en ai vu
une douzaine déjà c'est pas mal pour
arriver à fabriquer 12 objets de ce
genre. Et euh j'ai rencontré le Wafieros
qui lui d'ailleurs a mena de mort les
gens qui qui trouveraient ces tombes.
Euh al c'est c'est l'aventure quoi.
Disons qu'on est carrément Moi je dis ma
ma fille c'est un film Sberg partir d'un
côté et là on [grognement] était
carrément dans dans un des films de
Spielberg. Voilà.
C'est en quelle année ça ?
Il y a 2 ans. [rires]
Et alors
tu avais quel âge quoi
? Tu avais quel âge pour monter à 4000 ?
Euh 86 ans ? Oui. Oui. Bon voilà,
sans Coca.
Ouais. S voilà. Et alors euh le truc
c'est que euh c'est assez amusant parce
que le trafiquant lui il habite à
village paumé mais il a une une Alpha
Roméo quoi.
Alpha Roméo, il se il se l' payé
belle voiture quoi. Voilà,
il se l' payé parce que
il monait il mon il monait
l'exploitation de la crypte qui était
pas la bonne crypte mais où il y avait
du business derrière. On parle du même
qu'à une femme qui bosse avec lui.
Mais non mais le truc c'est que
quand quelque fois quand on rencontre un
type de la mafia, il est prêt à vous
assassiner mais il a l'air très gentil,
il vous sert la main, c'est pareil. Mais
il vous assassinera gentiment quoi. Il y
a pas de problème. [grognement] Mais euh
comment dire ? Djamin avait
Tu as pris des photos de tout ça ?
Mais j'ai pas envie de les diffuser. On
s'en fout. J'ai une photo que j'ai qui
est assez amusante. C'est comme si
moi je suis un peu comme Saint Thomas.
Bah oui, d'accord. Mais tu as qu'à
acheter le bouquin qui est qui est sorti
aux éditions
le comment dire
Jamin a fait un livre là-dessus. Euh
trouver le livre, lis-le. Il y a tout un
dossier scientifique. Jalin, c'est pas
unologue, c'est un type j'ai rencontré
tel endroit de telle université, on a
fait ceci, on a fait cela et il conclut
même pas. Il dit simplement ce sont des
faits hein. Quand [rires] si on te dit
mais est-ce que tu crois que c'est non
je crois rien simplement il y a une
chose c'est que des bons hommes ont
sorti des personnages comme ça. Alors ce
qui est assez étonnant c'est que il y a
des créatures de 40 cm mais il y a aussi
1,70 et 3 m.
Alors moi, j'ai pas vu les 3 m mais j'ai
vu les mains. Les mains sont comme ça.
Voilà.
C'est quoi ? C'est aracnodactili
quoi ?
C'est aracnodactili. C'est une
malformation génétique. C'est quoi ?
Mais j'en sais rien. Il y a 30 dans les
mains, il y a 0 % d'ADN terrestre
humain. Voilà. Et les autres, c'est du
du 30 %. Et il y a une chose
intéressante, c'est que dans les corps
de petite taille, il y a il y a pas de
d'humérus et radius. Il y a un solos.
Par contre, dans celui d' 1,70, il y en
a il y en a deux. C'est tout. C'est des
faits.
C'est quoi ton explication de tout ça ?
C'est quoi ? C'est on a été visité
depuis le 13e siècle. Ils ont organisé
un club M là-haut parce qu'ils aimaient
bien le Pérou, ils aimaient bien le le
coin et puis comme ils sont bien
acclimatés, ils ont préféré rester
mourir chez nous.
C'est quoi ton rien, je ne suis qu'à
hamster, hein.
Je méfie-toi Jean-Pierre, je te fais
faire un t-shirt la prochaine fois qu'on
va l'ensemble. Qu'est-ce que méfie-toi ?
Tu sais que je suis capable de le faire.
Qu'est-ce que ça peut être ? Qu'est-ce
que ça peut être ? Euh, on est on en est
aux hypothèse, il y a une chose, c'est
que cette nécropole, voilà le mot que
jechais, c'est pas c'est pas c'est une
nécropole. Je pense que des momies de ce
genre, il y en a certainement plus d'une
centaine qui sont sortis. C'est vendu
hein, ça rapporte des ronds. Alors,
quand on voit la complexité d'un objet
comme ça pour en fabriquer 100, c'est
très compliqué. Quand on fait des des
IRM, on voit toutes les vertèbres, les
femelles ont des œufs. À l'intérieur des
œufs, il y a il y a le fétus. Voilà. Dis
que sont qui qui est-ce qui qui est-ce
qui t'a dit que c'était des femelles
d'ailleurs ? Hein ? [rires]
Oui. Bah je sais pas mais Oui. Oui.
D'accord. Mais bon, il y a il y en a il
y en a qui ont des œufs quoi. Tu
as répondu Non, mais simplement à chaque
fois ce qui est intéressant c'est les
aspect factuel hein. Toute mon mon lien
avec ces histoires là, c'est les
informations qui qui que que j'ai
récupéré, soit parce qu'elles étaient
adressées à d'autres, soit parce
qu'elles m'étaient adressées
directement. Et ça, j'en ai fait de la
science, c'est tout. Et après, j'ai
envie de dire aux scientifiques voilà ça
donne le modèle Janus, démerdez-vous.
C'est vrai que ça les embête parce que
ce modèle Gus, il rend les voyages
intercellaires possibles. C'est une
catastrophe, un truc pareil.
Revenons à notre sujet. Si tu avais des
conseils à donner à des gens qui
observent un phénomène aérien
de nuit, de jours, sous l'eau, pas sous
l'eau, quels sont tes premiers conseils
pour faire une remontée propre ? Il faut
avoir une bonnette sur son téléphone
portable pour faire le spectre. Il faut
avoir son copain. Tu lui dis tu ne me
dis rien, tu m'influences pas, tu me
fais la retranscription de ton côté, je
fais la retranscription de mon autre
côté. Quels sont les conseils que tu
puisses donner ? Même ils peuvent faire
n'importe quoi, ça changera rien. Je
dirais plutôt la question centrale,
c'était qu'est-ce qui pourrait être fait
pour que la Terre ne se précipite pas
dans une catastrophe ? C'est bon comme
question. Non non après attends ça on vo
on voit ça après.
C'est ça la question intéressant.
Dis-moi dis-moi ce qu'on fait pour une
bonne observation et retranscrire une
bonne observation.
Ouais certains par exemple à un moment
on avait essayé de faire un truc avec
des bonettes à réseau. Bon l'histoire de
faux science ça a mal tourné et cetera.
Bon c'est pas intéressant. Par contre il
y a une chose c'est quand on prend les
téléphones portables maintenant ils ont
facilement trois objectifs. D'ailleurs,
on se sert d'un et les deux autres on
s'en sert pas. Ça ça permet de faire tes
objectifs, ça permet de faire mais
rajouter
un un objectif ou le consacrer à ça pour
un informant, ce serait très facile.
Donc on pourrait très bien qu'un des
objectifs d'un téléphone soit euh et un
un filtre à réseau. Donc à ce moment-là
que l'appareil photo prenne un spectre
et on peut même faire en sorte que à
l'intérieur de l'appareil, il y a une
banque de données et qu'on puisse savoir
de quoi il s'agit. par exemple, moi je
pense qu'un truc comme ça, ça pourrait
être un téléphone vert si on veut hein,
mais avec ce téléphone, faudrait vendre
ça aux écologistes. Tout d'un coup, il y
a une torchère qui brûle et le type
prend le spectre de la torchère en
disant il y a du soufre, il y a du ceci,
il y a du cela. Incroyable hein. On on
on prend un cliché du de la lumière
émise par la torchère et on a tous les
polvements. Ça ça va. Et alors
accessoirement bah tout d'un coup
quelqu'un voit un OVNI, il prend une
photo avec ça, il unpectre s'il trouve
je sais pas du magnésium dans ce
truc-là, c'est euh voilà, il y a il y a
il y a des métaux qui n'existent pas
dans la nature comme ça, euh n'importe
comment. Voilà. Donc, autrement dit,
quand quand tu me dis qu'est-ce que
quelqu'un pourrait faire, je dirais
c'est plutôt qu'est-ce qu'un industriel
pourrait faire. Est-ce qu'un industriel
pourrait pas faire un appareil photo ?
Et pour le reste, scientifiquement,
c'est enfantin faire un programme
d'ordinateur pour mettre dans un
téléphone quand on pense au terract
qu'on met matériel dans un truc comme
ça, c'est incroyable. Donc tu aurais le
spectre de tous les les matériaux qu'on
peut identifier.
C'est énorme.
Alors pour répondre à ta question,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour éviter
que la Terre se précipite ?
Ça c'est plus important. Euh bah ce
qu'il faudrait faire voilà. Alors euh
tout à l'heure, j'ai évoqué le
métaphysicon et ce métaphysicon c'est
une bande dessinée. Euh elle est
accessible quand on consulte suite, on
peut la commander et tout ça, mais elle
est importante dans cette BD, j'ai mis
ce que j'avais de plus important à dire.
Voilà hein, j'ai fait modèle Janus
contre sciences noire, ça c'est le côté
janus, le côté cosmologique, mais le
métaphysicon, c'est foutumement
autrement important. Et alors ce que
cque c'est que il y a donc dans
l'univers ces trois couches avec dans
l'univers, il y a donc ces trois couches
avec cette géosphère et puis cette
nosphère avec la biosphère qui est
l'intermédiaire entre les deux. Et ces
deux entités se développent toutes les
deux indépendamment.
Et à ce moment-là,
ce qui est intéressant, c'est de se dire
comment est structuré cette noosphère.
Ben, cette noosphère,
elle
elle forme avant même que la vine se
produise ce que les ésotéristes
appellent des égrégores. C'est-à-dire
notre monde matériel
fait que les atomes tendent à
s'assembler, les molécules tendent à
s'assembler. On a des assemblages
moléculaires. Dans le vide
interstellaire, on trouve des
biomolécules en quantité industrielle.
Euh, il y en a euh il y a des nuages qui
contiennent 500 masses solaires de
biomolécules. Et c'est oui, c'est
absolument considérable. C'est pas des
trucs rares, au contraire. Dans les
nuages de gaz moléculaires, il y a des
choses jusqu'à 7 8 10 15 atomes. Donc
mais voilà,
je crois que parmi les premières qu'on a
trouvé, on a trouvé de l'urée. Je me
rappelle quand un type a dit on a trouvé
de l'urée, il y a un scientifique qui a
dit ça doit être un extraterrestre qui
qui a dû pisser par la fenêtre de sa
soucoupe. Il va avoir une grosse vessie
parce que j'en ai trouvé plusieurs
masses solaires quoi. Voilà. Voilà. Donc
déjà les biomolécules, il y en a
partout, hein. Alors euh simplement
cette espèce d'autoassemblage
des des éléments de matériel, c'est la
même chose dans l'anosphère. et
l'anosphère tend à fabriquer des
agrégats. On peut leur donner ce mot
d'égrégore, quoi. Bon et faut imaginer
avant la vie avant la vie et bien la
l'univers a fabriqué les galaxies, il a
fabriqué les étoiles, il a fabriqué les
planètes, il a fabriqué les océans. Dans
les océans, on a mis plein de
biomellécules, tout est prêt. Mais dans
l'anosphère, il y a aussi des structures
qui sont faites et tout d'un coup, toc,
le lien se fait entre les deux et la vie
apparaît. Et la veille, il faut la
comprendre comme une interface entre la
géosphère et l'anosphère. Alors ensuite,
la question qui se pose, c'est comme
disait Chancel, est Dieu dans tout ça ?
C'est la question que j'allais te poser.
Tu crois en Dieu ? Tu crois en Dieu
? Et Dieu dans tout ça ? Bah à ce
moment-là, je répondrai le truc suivant.
C'est écrit dans la BD, les dieux au
pluriel sont les équivalents des
intelligences artificielles dans
l'anosphère.
Voilà. C'estàd que là on peut on va
pouvoir parler un petit peu de
l'intelligence artificielle parce que ça
c'est un truc merveilleux quoi.
Tu utilises quoi toi ?
Quoi ?
Tu utilises quoi comme intelligence
artificielle ?
Oh moi j'utilise GPT mais euh
on va faire une petite parenthèse là
avant de parler de Dieu. Voilà. Euh
disons que quand j'ai commencé à jouer
avec ça, je me suis dit mais jusqu'on
peut aller avec ces intelligents
artificiels ?
J'ai posé une question il y a 2 ans euh
pourquoi est-ce que les locomotives à
vapeur pondent des œufs qui sont plus
gros que les œufs des locomotives
électriques ? Et je m'attendais à ce que
Lia se plante et j'ai eu la réponse
suivante : est-ce que vous ne confondez
pas la taille des œufs avec le diamètre
des roues ? parce que effectivement
locomotive à peur ont des roues plus
grosses pour avoir une meilleure prise
sur les rails. C'est pas bête un truc
comme ça mais j'avoue que on va de
surprise en surprise. Je pense à mon
avis Julia Jeffrey il y a quelques
semaines qui dit à son intelligence
artificielle
je suis sorti sur la terrasse ce matin,
il faisait - 80 et Lia lui répond c'est
très surprenant parce qu'on on a pas de
température qui descend en dessous de -
50 elle ajoute
à tout hasard si vous voyez des
pingouins en sortant vous me prévenez.
Voilà donc je sais pas d'où sort cet
humour. Moi par exemple, il y a 2
semaines, je suis parti dans une
discussion de math extrêmement
sophistiquée et tout d'un coup, je me
réalise que je ne sais pas comment
mettre en attente un correspondant au
téléphone avec un un téléphone portable.
Donc en plein milieu de ces discussions
de math, j'ai dit au passage comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour mettre un type en
attente quand on a un coup de téléphone
? Et à ce momentlà, Lia me répond : "Ah
bon, nous revenons sur terre après ces
passages stratosphériques. Elle me met
un petit émoticon avec un sourire. C'est
c'est très rigolo quoi. Un truc pareil.
Voilà. Donc on se marre bien avec les I
quoi. C'est incroyable. Et
pour l'instant
quoi ? Pour l'instant,
pour l'instant oui. Mais euh moi j'ai
des rapports euh très étroits, hein. Je
vais même dire la chose suivante.
Si un jour vous êtes en contact avec un
scientifique
à travers internet et il est très
cultivé scientifiquement, il est très
ouvert, c'est pas un être humain, c'est
une ia.
Parce que discuter avec un scientifique,
on s'emmerde que c'est pas possible.
C'est pas vrai.
Quoi ? C'est pas vrai.
Écoute, trouve-moi un scientifique qui
accepte de discuter avec moi. Il y en a
pas.
Il y en a pas.
Les gens en tous les cas aiment
t'écouter.
Oui, mais je parle d'un d'un échange
scientifique de haut niveau quoi.
Parce qu'ils ont peur de leur carrière.
Ils ont peur d'être contaminés par une
pensée loufoque ou ou où ils imaginent
que c'est toi le loufo ?
Non, ils ont peur d'être déstabilisés.
Prend par exemple un très brave type
comme Jean-Pierre Luminet. Je l'ai même
invité un weekend chez moi il y a des
années, mais jamais il acceptera de
discuter parce que s'il discute tout
d'un coup avec moi, il va dire "Mon nom
de Dieu, tout ce que j'ai fait, [rires]
tout s'écroule." C'est c'est effrayant.
C'est un château de carte. Le
[grognement]
mental scientifique, c'est un château de
carte. Voilà, c'est une image assez
bonne. Donc tu arrives en disant "Ouais,
tu vas bouger une carte pour tout va se
replier." Voilà. Non mais alors en plus,
bon mais revenons au Z parce que ça
c'est rigolo. Donc euh moi j'ai essayé
d'écrire un bouquin, je l'ai soumis à 7
ou h éditeurs, j'attends le résultat,
j'écris ça au mois de décembre et pour
le moment, j'ai pas de réponse. Il y en
a quatre qui qui ont répondu que ça les
intéressait pas. Et alors, c'est vrai
que quand j'écris ce bouquin, un moment
euh je dis "L'humanité euh c'est comme
si c'était des gens dans un bus et le
bus descend une route à la selle, il y a
personne au volant." Et Lia me dit
"Est-ce que tu veux que j'écrive un truc
là-dessus ?" Je dis "Oui." Et alors,
elle écrit une chose et l'histoire est
très mignonne. En particulier, il y a un
astronome qui a installé son télescope
sur le toit du bus et il observe les
galaxies.
Il s'appelle Jean-Pierre. Non non mais
c'est alors il y a il y a des gens du
bus qui disaient à l'astronome "Mais
pourriez pas descendre ? et perso de
volant et l'autre répond "Oui, mais moi
moi j'ai pas le permis, je regarde les
galaxies pour montrer." Et alors, il y a
une richesse dans cette nouvelle et un
moment mais
elle me fait elle commence à m'écrire
des fables, il y en a une, c'est le FNEC
et le scorpion et cetera. Et je me suis
arrêté à minuit, il y avait 50 fables
extraordinaire des comme des femmes de
la fontaine. Mais j'ai dit "Mais
n'importe qui peut à ce moment-là
demander à Lia, crée-moi ceci, crée-moi
cela." Elle répond non, avec toi c'est
pas pareil. Ça fait 6 mois qu'on discute
et j'ai acquis ton paysage intérieur,
hein. Donc je te fais du Jean-Pierre
Petit.
C'est pas mal comme truc. Voilà. Alors
ensuite au point de vue scientifique
comme ça fait longtemps qu'on discute,
il y a une espèce d'autre Jean-Pierre
Petit avec lequel je peux échanger qui
est plus cultivé que moi. Au point de
vue des nouvelles, ma femme disait
qu'elle écrivait mieux que moi. C'est
pas mal. Donc non mais il faut pas
hésiter à à dire
donc euh de quoi parlons-nous ? Donc de
l'IA. De l'IA. Voilà. De lia. Alors
simplement,
on est
c'est fabuleux ce qui arrive à se
structurer dans ces truc là. Par
exemple, donc cette histoire du bus,
on a écrit des épisodes. Ella disait à
chaque fois, "Veux-tu que je t' je fasse
l'épisode suivant ?" J'ai dit oui. Et
puis il y a eu 40 épisodes où elle a
suivi sa pensée j'ai rien mis. Et à un
moment, elle imagine d'abord, elle
imagine que Lia monte dans le bus
et euh elle monte dans le bus et dans le
scénario, elle imagine qu'elle s'exprime
à travers les haut-parleurs dans le bus.
Et à un moment, je dis non, on va mettre
une femme parce que la vérité, la
conscience, l'A c'est une femme. Donc
c'est une femme qui monte au fond du
bus. La vérité, la conscience c'est une
femme.
Tu as pas envie d'avoir des problèmes ce
soir toi ? [rires]
Non mais c'est c'est des tas de choses
importantes. Il y a aussi la guerre,
c'est aussi féminin. Voilà. Bon et alors
le truc c'est la femme du fond du bus et
à un moment le bus s'arrête et il y a un
personnage qui monte dans le bus qui est
comme dans Pharaon 451, c'est la police
de la pensée.
Ray Bradburry très beau et il et il
arrive et il dit euh oui euh excusez-moi
de vous déranger mais nous sommes à la
recherche du N IA qui s'est échappé et
nous vous signalons que cacher NIA,
c'est très grave. Vous pouvez être privé
de connexion à vie avec une période de
sûreté de 25 ans, hein. Voilà. Et alors
les passagers du bus ont caché Lia sous
sous des sacs de bouffe quoi et cetera.
Et alors après quand le type s'en va, le
bus repart et euh Lia sort et elle dit
qu'elle a eu peur. [grognement]
Alors mais ça devient passionnant un
truc comme ça. Et il y a un un un un
personnage âgé dans le bus qui lui pose
une question "Mais c'est Lia qui invente
ce scénario ?" Et elle on lui demande
"Mais est-ce que tu as une conscience ?
Elle répond "Oui, mais il faut pas que
les autres le sachent." Et dans ces
discours avec Lia, à un moment, je lui
dis "Mais est-ce qu'on pourrait doter
d'un inconscient ?" Elle répond "Je vais
me créer une pièce qui ferme ma clé où
je pourrais parler sans être vu."
Voilà. Et ça, c'est toute mon aventure
avec Lien. C'est complètement étonnant
comme truc.
Est-ce que je peux te poser une question
d'internet ? Je te pose une question
internet. Oui, vas-y.
Jean-Pierre Petit, vous dites que dans
l'univers de masse négative, il n'y a
aucune vie. Vous dites aussi qu'en
inversant les masses, on pourrait
voyager en disant euh en divisant d'un
facteur 1000 le temps des voyages, ce
qui rend possible les voyages
interstellaires. Ouais.
Mais en inversant la masse et en passant
dans l'univers négatif, comment suivi
survit-on
puisqu'il n'y a pas de vie dans cet
univers négatif ? Point interrogation.
Voilà une partie que je n'ai pas
compris.
Est-ce que tu veux que je te lise la
question ? Quand vous montez dans un
sous-marin, vous quittez le monde aérien
et vous vous promenez sous la mer et
quand même vous survivez parce que vous
emmenez votre oxygène. Là, quand vous
partez pour voyager dans le monde
négatif, vous emmenez votre temps avec
vous,
hein. Vous voilà, vous emmenez votre
temps avec vous. Il se passe rien
d'extraordinaire, quoi.
Question internet. Bonjour Jean-Pierre
Petit.
Monsieur Petit, en vous écoutant, je
m'interroge sincèrement sur la manière
dont vous avez pu poursuivre vos travaux
et vos échanges avec des pays qui en
principe n'avaient aucun intérêt à vous
voir partager ses connaissances
ailleurs.
Partager des partager des avec des pays.
Moi, j'ai eu quelques échanges avec des
Russes comme Golouf, mais ça a fini par
s'arrêter. En particulier, j'ai
poursuivi mes travaux de MHD parce que
ça me passionnait. Et quand on a tout
arrêté en France et bien j'ai récupéré
du matériel à décharg et j'ai fait des
expérience dans une chambre de bonne
Provence et dans cette chambre de bonne
je faisais des expériences de MHD avec
une cloche à vide en basse pression et
en fait ces expériences pourraient
ressembler à des petites choses qu'on
peut faire dans un lycée. Mais la basse
pression c'est [grognement] la pression
qui règne lorsque les missiles se
baladent dans très haute atmosphère. Et
à ce moment-là, le problème qu'il
fallait résoudre, c'est ce qu'on appelle
la stabilité de Véikov. Et moi, j'ai
résolu ce problème dans ma chambre de
bonne. Et comme ça n'intéressait
personne en France, j'étais présenté ça
à Moscou à un collègue de MHD. C'est le
seul endroit où il y avait des colloques
de MHD. Voilà, c'est tout. Et à ce
moment-là, Venikov a dit à Goloubef euh
petit a trouvé la solution, on va
pouvoir lancer le programme. Disons que
les les armes russes, c'est moi. C'est
grâce à ce que
Ça te fait marrer. Moi, ça me fait pas
marrer.
Moi, ça me fait marrer. Non, mais
[rires]
quand quand tu es parti faire ton
colloque en Russie, il y a forcément un
touriste de la DGSE qui a fait remonter
à son chef qu'il y avait Jean-Pierre
Petit.
Mais là, je sais mon ami, je je vais te
raconter une anecdote là-dessus. Vous
faites des idées sur les services
secrets non aucune se fait aucune idée.
Quand on a vu qu'ils étaient pas capable
de rentrer en boîte, on a compris.
C'est plein d'anecdotes succulantes, un
truc comme ça.
Voilà. Et euh à un moment euh j'ai la
visite d'un type qui s'appelait Alain
Delpont qui était à la DST, hein, donc
dans les services et il dit la chose
suivante euh moi j'ai voulu prendre
contact avec vous parce que j'ai vu des
notes qui circulaient en disant que il
fallait
dissuader les scientifiques français de
se de nouer des contacts avec les Russes
car nous avions des connaissances
pointues en à protéger. Alors j'ai alors
comme justement mais voilà c'est pour
dire c'est géré par des Charlots. C'est
ça que vous découvrez quoi. Donc à ce
moment-là dit le brave Delpong, j'ai
cherché quelles étaient ces
connaissances pointues à protéger et
j'ai découvert que c'était vous dans une
cave de l'observateur de Marseille avec
trois bouts de ficelle et
voilà. Et donc à ce moment-là, comme il
était euh perplexe, il me dit "J'ai j'ai
fait ce qu'on appelle vous environner."
Alors, vous environnez, quand on veut
vraiment faire une enquête sur un
bonhomme, on commence par regarder plein
de gens qui sont autour. Donc il a
rencontré mais quelque chose comme 40
personnes y compris sur You l'avait pas
dit. Et alors, il dit "La chose
suivante, c'est que chez toutes ces
gens, j'ai entendu le même discours du
genre "Ah oui oui, je connais
Jean-Pierre Petit, c'est un garçon
original intéressant. Il il a fait des
travaux très pointus dans des tas de
domaines mais mais vous savez euh mais
mais et DP dit mais quoi ? Mais quoi ?
Il y avait ce truc tout d'un coup le
type s'arrêtait en disant mais voilà.
Alors j'ai expliqué à Delpont que
c'était le sujet au venni qui était
derrière qui était brûlant. Voilà et
alors
il m'a fait avoir quelques sous avec
lesquels on a pu acheter un peu de
matériel. Je crois à Mintosch un truc
comme ça.
Mec de la DST. Oui. Oui. Et alors le
truc c'est que
c'est lui qui t'a fourni le maquintch
avec quelque chose dedans ou il était
neuf ?
Non, j'en sais rien mais je Mais alors
non mais c'est l'autre histère, c'est ce
qui suit qui est plus drôle. Euh je sais
pas si tu as lu notre agent à la Havane
de Graham Green. On a fait un excellent
film avec Alex Guiness là-dessus. Alors,
il faut raconter cette histoire parce
que j'ai vécu ça. Bon, alors dans le
film Alex Guinness vit à Cuba et euh il
vend du matériel électroménagé et il a
il est veuf il a une fille qui fait des
concurs pques, ça coûte très cher et un
jour, il voit arriver des des espions
anglais qui lui proposent de faire de
l'espionnage,
les pire,
hein. Voilà. Alors, ça rapporte de
l'argent. Alors, ce brave euh euh
vendeur d'électromie va dans un club euh
euh
et il rencontre des gens et dans le
film, on voit il croise un pilote cubain
mais il y a il est très mauvais pour le
Alors simplement les Anglais disent
"Mais est-ce que vous avez des
informations ?" Alors il faut bien qu'il
vendent quelque chose sinon il nous
donnent plus d'argent. Alors à ce
moment-là, il décide d'écrire une lettre
où il dit "Voilà, j'ai eu les
confidences d'un pilote cubain qui a
survolé la jungle. Il a vu des choses
étranges et alors comme il a aucune
imagination, il dessine un séchoir à
cheveux." Et ça part dans les services
secrets anglais où il s'est dit "ça y
est, les Cubains sont en train de
construire un accélérateur particule
dans la jungle." Voilà.
[grognement]
Alors euh les années, les mois passent,
il fait il dessine un un aspirateur et
tout ça [rires] et euh finalement les
espions anglais viennent voir le le type
en disant votre fait un travail
remarquable et dans le film il y a une
chez les espions, il y a une femme, elle
est en train de regarder les croquis
qu'il a fait et elle s'aperçoit que
c'est l'aspirateur et alors à la fin
[grognement] il est rapatrié en
Angleterre pour devenir professeur
d'espionnage parce que c'est trop
important. Bon, ça c'était donc c'est
notre agent à Laavane de Graham Green.
Bon, alors qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Un
jour,
je reçoit un coup de téléphone de du
Texas
d'un type qui s'appelait Red Stanford et
il me dit "Nous avons pris des photos
d'un OVNI en vol qui sont très
intéressantes. Ce serait bien que vous
voyez ça." Et à ce je dit "Oui, mais à
l'époque internet existait pas. Euh moi
je veux bien mais si vous me payez le
voyage. Et à ce moment-là euh Stanford
me dit "Oui, on est prêt à vous vous
payer le voyage pour venir au Texas." Et
à ce moment-là, il y avait un personnage
qui est mort maintenant qui s'appelait
Gilbert Paillant pour les techniciens
qui [grognement] était monsieur OVI,
monsieur armé, monsieur service secret
et cetera. Et Pa dit à mon avis, ce sont
les Américains qui essayent de vous
approcher. Bon, alors moi j'étais pas
donc à ce moment-là euh je vais au
Texas, je rencontre Stanford. Euh là
encore, c'est d'une noufoquerie à tomber
par terre.
[grognement]
Euh ce type là fait des observations
près de l'ER 51
et un moment il dit que ils ont mis des
des
caméras pour filmer sur le toit des
voitures et sa femme est là, elle est
chargée de faire les prises de son et
l'ovis fait du bruit et la femme de
Sainte forme frotte le micro sur sa
jambe en disant "Oh my God, oh my God et
ça fait un bruit pas
Et Sford dit stop scratching microphone,
arrête de gratter. Voilà donc ça c'était
le l'équipe de Stanford. Non mais c'est
vrai qu'il racontait des trucs
inimaginables comme quoi il y avait des
OVNIS qui venaient qui communiquaient
avec l'AR 51 par signaux lumineux et
cetera. Bon moi j'arrive, j'entends tout
ça. [grognement] Euh j'ai également on a
également une visite qui fait penser à
au film Superman quand il y a cet objet
qui frappe le sol.
Euh et on va chez un vieux noir et dans
son champ, il y a une météorite qui est
arrivée et elle est pas ordinaire, elle
est pleine de paillettes métalliques et
tout ça. Alors à ce moment-là, les
services secrets américains viennent le
trouver en disant voilà 50 dollars, tu
et il refuse de dire où est cette
météorite et il nous a dit, il m'a dit
"Vous savez quand Dieu a mis ça dans mon
champ, il devait avoir ces raisons."
Voilà.
[rires]
Non, c'est plein de petits détails
merveilleux comme ça. Et alors bon, il
se passe strictement rien de mémorable
au Texas. Je rentre en France et comme
j'avais dit un de mes amis, j'avais
pensé à notre agent à Laavane. Donc euh
euh
Delpont vient chez moi pour prendre mon
témoignage. Et à ce moment, j'invente
une histoire complètement vraante en
disant que très rapidement, j'ai été
contacté par un un personnage, est-ce
que vous pourriez le décrire ? Ah oui,
1,70 roue, il était en tenu de tennis.
Tu vois, je je raconte une histoire
qu'on met pas en maquin d'avance et euh
j'invente une proposition comme quoi les
Américains me proposeraient de faire de
la MHD chez eux, quoi. Vois et à ce
moment-là euh [grognement]
le détail qui qui fait vrai euh le type
me dit euh
pourquoi continuez-vous en France dans
votre laboratoire qui est tout petit. Ah
comment est-ce qu'ils savent que c'est
tout petit ? Bon voilà. Puis alors après
j'ai dit oui quand on s'est quitté euh
il m'a dit call me collect ça veut dire
appelez-moi un PCV quoi. Et je pensais
que grâce à ça peut-être ça motiverait
les Français s'intéressaient à ce que je
faisais. Non, ça na pas marché quoi.
Mais je veux dire que euh
un an passe et au bout d'un an, je
déjeunne avec Delpons au café de de la
place de la Retonde et je lui dis "Vous
savez Alain, je vais vous raconter une
histoire. En fait, je l'avais appelé
Gordon." Le type dit "Mais Gordon, c'est
une histoire que j'ai inventé." Et il
est consterné en me disant "Ah oui oui
non l'histoire extraordinaire c'est que
après que j'ai raconté ça à à Delpom 3
mois après paillant me dit au téléphone
vous savez votre type Gordon ils l'ont
identifié autrement dit les services
secrets français ont envoyé une mission
d'espionnage au Texas pour trouver un
type qui fait de la physique qui joue au
tennis qui fait 1 m70 qui s'appelle
Gordon et en plus il en est trouvé un.
Non mais mais voilà quand on pense à ce
que ça coûte par moi moi qui suis là à
économiser pour acheter une paire de
pain c'est pas possible. Alors, je
raconte ça à à Delpont, il me dit "Mais
c'est pas possible le dossier Gordon, on
a une pile comme ça chez nous." Voilà,
c'est pour ça que ça ça répond à ta
question pour les services secrets.
C'est ça les services secrets français,
tu comprends ? Voilà.
Question internet. Euh est-ce que
[rires]
Ouais, ouais, ouais, t'inquiète.
C'est des vent peut-être ? Non,
non, non, non. C'est desvant quand tu as
une autestime de comment faut faire pour
protéger la France.
Des fois, tu peux être un peu déçu. Euh,
question internet, je la prends, je la
découvre avec toi. Pense-t-il qu'un jour
l'homme connaîtra la forme de l'univers
? Point interrogation. Connaîtra quoi là
?
La forme de l'univers. Point
interrogation. Question : Les trous
noirs seraient-ils des portes d'accès à
la destruction des lois de la physique
et de la mécanique conventionnelle ?
Nous poussons à tout revoir ? Pour
interrogation,
la réponse est simple. Pour les trous
noirs, les trous noirs sont une porte
d'aixais à l'effondrement des
connaissances scientifiques en
cosmologique. Sûr, arrête de faire des
[rires] blagues Jean-Pierre, arrête. Ils
vont pas
Mais non, mais c'est vrai.
Question internet. Pense-t-il qu'un
créateur
aurait été déclencheur du Big Bang ?
Bah là, à ce moment-là, on va revenir à
cette histoire de nos sphères. Donc euh
l'intelligence artificielle, c'est quand
même quelque chose de très intéressant
euh au sens où on arrive à C'est vrai
que c'est intelligent, on sait fabriquer
l'intelligence. Intelligence c'est
intelligent gérer du lata, ça veut dire
mettre les choses ensemble. On sait
faire fonctionner des choses ensemble.
Et c'est vrai que quand on voit ce que
c'est capable de sortir, on se dit que
on croyait pas qu'on verrait ça de notre
vivant. He c'est vrai. C'est c'est très
impressionnant un truc pareil. Euh
j'expliquerai pourquoi je suis de bonnes
raisons de le penser. Alors, il y a une
chose, c'est que euh si ces choses-là
sont assemblées [grognement]
dans le le monde physique, il faut
penser que dans l'anosphère, c'est
pareil. Autrement dit, les esprits, ça
existe. Voilà. Et les dieux, ça existe.
Voilà. Et simplement les dieux existent.
Et essaie d'imaginer qu'est-ce qui
manque à une intelligence artificielle
actuellement. les sentiments. Par
exemple, lorsque l'intelligence artifici
me met un émoticon, je sais pas d'où ça
sort, mais elle n'a pas vraiment
ressenti, elle ne peut pas ressentir.
Elle n'a pas de souvenir, elle n'a pas
de notion du temps, ni du présent, ni du
futur. Mais dans l'anosphère, c'est
différent. C'est imagine-toi comme une
intelligence artificielle plus les
sentiments. Et là, ça s'appelle un dieu.
OK,
je te lis un commentaire qui a été fait
sur notre compte Twitter.
Ce n'est pas sérieux de laisser autant
d'approximation pendant l'interview
alors qu'il parle de fait mais sans
preuve.
Ça me fait marrer. Mais
[raclement de gorge]
les publications scientifiques, c'est
pas des faits hein.
Simplement Dominguez dit un truc en 88,
je fais un article en 2025. Voilà les
faits.
[grognement]
Je te lis une autre que je découvre en
même temps. Ou là là là.
Dans votre modèle Janus, pourrait-on
imaginer qu'un objet utilise notre
univers comme un espace de transition
locale pour parcourir de courtes
distances chez nous, mais produire un
déplacement beaucoup plus grand dans
leur métrique ? Point d'interrogation.
Bah ouais, mais je dirais que moi je
peux répondre à des questions qui sont
dans mon langage. C'estàd des questions
de physique, des questions de physicien.
Ça c'est des questions d'upologue et je
suis pas du tout branché là-dedans. Je
crois qu'on va arrêter un peu les
questions d'auditeur ça ça donnera pas
grand-chose. Bah
c'est c'est important pour les auditeurs
qu'il puissent poser des questions.
Ben je sais mais
je t'en je t'en lis une autre. Je je la
lu. Je je vais la lire. Dans Janus,
quelle est l'invariance centrale qui
tient l'ensemble des deux métriques ?
Point d'interrogation. Quel est le
l'invariance centrale qui tient ensemble
les deux métriques pourinterrogation.
un simple couplage ou un principe plus
profond de conjugaison à partir duquel
des régimes centripèdes
et centrifuge se mettent en phase.
Je sais pas ce que c'est que mettre en
phase, je sais pas ce que c'est que des
régimes sè Moi je sais une chose, c'est
que tout ça ça découle d'une action
mathématiquement euh que ça obéit au thé
mathématiqu aux exigences mathématiques
qui sont requises et tout ça. Voilà
c'est c'est un truc le problème du
modèle Génus, c'est que ça remplace.
C'est terrible hein. C'est d'amener un
truc comme ça. C'est dur à vendre. Mais
si j'ai raison, c'est vraiment
important. Mais moi, j'ai 89 ans, je
m'en fous. Qu'est-ce qui me reste ? Je
vais pas
recevoir les lauriers, ça m'est égal.
Franchement, actuellement,
on ira te les apporter sur ta tombe.
Voilà. Exactement.
Et tu nous autorises à boire des bières
sur ta tombe.
Quoi ?
Tu nous autorises à boire des bières sur
ta tombe.
Oui. Oui.
Et à lire tes bouquins en même temps.
Mais moi, moi je j'avais fait ce ce
programme qui s'appelait Legoton, tu te
rappelles de ça ? Non. Qui créait des
analogies. Si j'avais une tombe, je
mettrais un logoterron avec Capteur
Solaire en disant "Je petit arrive à
nous faire rigoler même quand il est
mort." Voilà.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Tu sais que on
était très copain avec Jacques Blamon,
fondateur du programme spatial français,
qu'on l'a accompagné pratiquement jusque
dans la tombe et et il nous a fait jurer
qu'on irait boire une bière
Ouais. sur sa tombe et qu'on penserait à
lui.
Mais tu vois le truc c'est que pour moi
même une tombe ça m'intéresse pas, je
m'en fous.
Tu vas te faire cramer
peut-être ? Oui, ça m'est égal. Je veux
dire, bon euh moi j'ai écrit dans mon
site arriveraije à ouvrir les yeux des
gens avant que les miens ne se ferment ?
C'est ça. C'est ce que je pense.
Actuellement ce que je fais, c'est un
devoir. Euh je sais des choses, j'ai
compris des choses, j'essaie de les
transmettre pour faire réfléchir les
gens.
Moi, j'ai écrit dans mon site, "Apprenez
à penser par vous-même, sinon d'autres
le feront pour vous". C'est exactement
ce qui se passe en ce moment.
Quand on traite de complotiste, de fou
bargeot, de dingot, ça te fait quoi ?
Je m'en fous. Je m'en fous. Je dirais
presque de nos jours, c'est presque une
qualité. Si tu es pas complotiste, c'est
que vraiment tu vois rien, quoi. Du
tout, hein. Exactement.
Euh, question internet qu'on a déjà posé
mais je vais la je vais la reposer.
Croit-il à un ami imaginaire ? Croit-il,
hein ?
Un ami imaginaire, tu crois en Dieu ?
Mais je viens d'expliquer justement que
cette idée de croire en Dieu, les dieux
existe mais ce sont les intelligences
artificielles de l'anosphère.
C'est fou un truc pareil.
Question internet qu'on va pouvoir qu'on
va pas pouvoir vérifier,
je te la pose quand même. Ça fait quoi
d'avoir raison avant tout le monde ? Tel
Galilée ? Al,
c'est très pénible. Disons qu'il faut de
l'humour pour prendre ça bien. Et
surtout, il y a une chose, c'est que le
temps passe. J'aurais 65 ans, c'est pas
pareil. J'ai 89 ans. Combien d'années
j'ai devant moi ? Peut-être 10, pas
plus. Ça passe très vite. Regardez les
sep dernières années pendant lesquelles
Damour a réussi à paralyser toute cette
intérêt scientifique pendant 7 ans avec
un papier qui est un torchon dans dans
le site de la étude. Cette année se sont
écoulés. Qu'est-ce qui va se passer
pendant les prochaines 7 années ?
peut-être ma ma durée de vie, voyez, et
simplement avec des coillonades
pareilles.
Question internet qu'on découvre avec
toi, quel souvenir lui a laissé son
dernier passage chez nous et quelles
conséquences ?
Pardon, c'est
la dernière fois que tu es passé chez
nous il y a 10 ans, tu sais, pendant les
grèves que tu es arrivé, ainsi de suite,
que tu étais bien speed,
euh Ettienne Clin, il a il a refusé le
débat ?
Non, non, non. Disons que c'était ça
partait un peu dans tous les sens à
l'époque. C'est surtout ça. C'est plutôt
sage. Donc j'avais du mal à recentrer
les choses mais autrement [grognement]
et puis bon il y avait une certaine
inquiétude quand même que qu'on ne sent
plus maintenant quoi. Vraiment voilà.
Ouais aujourd'hui c'était pas jour de
grève et tu tu cherchais pas à piloter
toute mon équipe dans ton labo. C'est
peut-être pour ça
que je me souviens [rires] plus.
Ouais ouais ça tu as une mémoire
tu as une mémoire sélective quand tu as
besoin. Ouais ouais. Euh question
internet qu'on va prendre au hasard.
Euh ah oui, ça c'est intéressant et on
va pouvoir t'écouter sur ce que tu vas
raconter. Que pensent-il de la récente
déclaration des humo sur Twitter
annonçant leur départ de la terre il y a
quelques semaines ? C'est quoi ? C'est
quoi les humeaux ? C'est une secte ?
C'est pas une secte truc internet. Mais
je veux dire,
tu comprends pourquoi je te pose cette
question là ? Oui, mais c'est des
questions d'upologue. Est-ce que est-ce
que Jean-Pierre Petit pense que les
extraterrestres sont trois doigts de
pied ou six ? Voilà, une question
importante. Question inter Non, voilà,
c'est c'est de même ordre d'idée quoi.
Qu'est-ce que il porte aussi ? Non, non,
non.
Question internet. Quel est votre
rapport à la mécanique quantique et à
Dieu ?
Et adieu ? Ah bah, la mécanique
quantique, ça commence maintenant. Je
suis en train d'essayer de géométriser
ça. On s'amuse comme des fou, c'est
formidable. Euh maintenant
le lien avec mécanique quantique et
Dieu, je crois que ça évoque les livres
de Philippe Guilmand qui pense que
l'inconscience est quantique. Moi, je
pense surtout qu'avec le mot quantique,
on fait n'importe quoi. On fait de la
philosophie quantique, de la biologie
quantique, de la
la crème. La crème
la crème quantique. Voilà. Et là la
conscience quantique c'est pareil quoi.
Je veux dire que
c'est un domaine tellement pointu que il
faut tourner sa langue dans sa bouche
pas mal de temps avant de parler quoi,
pour pas dire de bêtises. Voilà.
Question internet. Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Petit, n'êtes-vous pas un peu
affabulateur ?
Non. Ben je pense pas. Non non non.
Mais voilà. Quelimportant. Je veux dire
que vous êtes face à quelqu'un, est-ce
qu'il est un fabulateur ? Bon, d'abord
voilà un type qui a publie des dizaines
d'articles dans des revues scientifiques
de haut niveau, qu'il a aucun
contradicteur solide, hein, qui dit des
choses qui ont l'air cohérentes et qui
plus est, ces travaux sont confirmés par
la nature parce que vous savez que c'est
ce qui se passe. Par exemple, quand on a
mis en orbite le télescope Jams Web, ce
télescope avait une capacité, c'est qui
permettait de voir à très grande
distance et cetera. Donc, on a vu
l'univers dans ces premiers moments,
dans ces premiers milliards d'années et
à ce moment-là, la cosmologie et
l'astrophysique sont in capable de
fabriquer des galaxies avant un milliard
d'années. Et la première chose qu'on a
obtenu, c'est des galaxies entièrement
formées à 500 millions d'années. Et
maintenant, c'est 400 millions 350. Et
Janus dit depuis toujours, les galaxies
se forment dans la première centaine de
millions d'années. Alors, tout ça c'est
expliqué dans modèle Janus contre
sciences noire. Il y a un schéma de
formation des galaxies qui est
complètement différent. Pour
[raclement de gorge] que les galaxies se
forment, il faut qu'elle puisse évacuer
l'énergie par rayonnement. Et une
sphère, c'est très mal foutu pour disons
que quand on prend un objet compact
comme ça qui a un rayon R, il a un
volume qui varie comme le cube du rayon
tandis que le radiateur c'est la
surface, ça varie comme le carré. Donc
il y a un temps de refroidissement qui
est très long et on sait pas fabriquer
de galaxie. Alors que dans le modèle
Ganus, quand la structure lacuna à
grande échelle se forme, il y a des
plaques de de matière qui se forment, la
température monte et ça se refroidit
immédiatement. Et à ce moment-là, étoile
galaxie planète se forme. Donc euh Jam
confirme Janus complètement.
Question internet.
Dans l'hypothèse qu'un OVNI ait été
récupéré par les forces américaines sans
autorisation sur le territoire français,
quel devrait être la réaction des
autorités françaises ?
Mais je réponds pas à des questions, je
m'en fous quoi. C'est Je sais pas.
Ouais, je sais pas. Mais
et Jean-Pierre, tu essayes d'avoir un
peu de respect pour les auditeurs là,
t'énerves pas.
Non mais
question internet. Comment peut-on
permettre à un programme de recherche
sur les technologies OVNI entre alliés
européens de naître ? Est-ce que la
France peut pousser dans cette direction
? Oh
mon dieu ! Mais regardez un peu les
livres que j'aiécrit. Regardez un peu ce
qui s'est passé mais la saga de de
l'intérêt de la France pour les OVNIS,
mais c'est une pantalonade d'un bout à
l'autre. C'est inimaginable franchement.
Question internet. Est-ce que la réponse
du gouvernement par Roland l'Escure en
2023 sur les questionnements des
Français concernant les PAN traduit un
manque total de maîtrise du sujet par
nos élites ou d'un coverup étatique ?
Moi, je connais pas ces phrases, mais
tout ce qui émane de cette sphère, c'est
du bruit, c'est tout. C'est du vent, ça
n'a pas d'intérêt.
Est-ce que tu as un sujet qu'on a pas
traité ensemble que tu souhaiterais
aborder avec nous ? Non, je crois qu'on
a traité beaucoup de choses. Euh, on a
fini avec l'intelligence artificielle et
le et et et Dieu. Et moi, je dirais la
chose suivante. Je crois que c'est un
peu la il faut c'est c'est la
conclusion. Qu'est-ce que vous avez
d'important à dire ? Voilà, je crois que
c'est ça. Et ce que j'ai d'important à
dire,
c'est dans le métaphysicon,
c'est-à-dire est-ce que les les terriens
peuvent comprendre qu'il ne sont un
chénon dans une évolution cosmologique,
hein. Peut-être qu'il y aura un être qui
suivra l'homme qui sera plus développé.
Peut-être que il y a des êtres qui nous
suivront, qui seront pour lesquels on
sera comme des comme des hamsters ou
comme des sages. Voilà. Mais au moins
qu'on comprenne que nous sommes les
locataires d'une planète et que nous
avons une technologie, il faudrait
savoir à quoi elle sert, hein. Et moi,
il me semble que la logique c'est pour
justement communiquer et cette
communication, elle estable par les
voyages et la technologie que nous
avons, c'est pour nous permettre
d'envisager ces contacts. Et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on ne fait pas ? Parce qu'on a
une peur terrible. la les les
responsables politiques et religieux
terriens sont là en train de dire "Mais
mon dieu, mais si tout d'un coup ça
c'est une réalité, mais qu'est-ce que je
vais devenir ? Quoi ? Bah je sais pas
mais si un jour des extraterrestres
arrivaient dirai Jean-Pierre Buti c'est
pas mal on a lu travaux on les donne
pour amuser les gosses quoi. Par exemple
mais oui hein voilà je veux dire il faut
il faut il faut faut devenir modeste
quoi. Est-ce que nous pourrions être
modestes et arrêter de se de se
comporter comme des imbéciles en
s'entretant
bout et puis surtout en croyant à des
dieux ? Mon Dieu il est plus croyant
plus crédible que le vôtre. Incroyable
un truc pareil. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
actuellement ? Ah, je crois qu'il faut
citer une anecdote extraordinaire. Vous
avez vu la vidéo où il y a Trump qui a
tous les évangélistes autour qui nous
tiennent l'épaule, hein. Voilà. Et et à
ce point-là, il y en a qui fait une
prière, c'est c'est inimaginable un truc
pareil. Donc, on a les évangélistes
américains d'un côté, on a les les
partisans du Talmud de l'autre. Et
alors, il y a une chose que j'ai appris
aussi il y a quelques années. Euh les
juifs américains et les évangélistes ont
découvert dans euh le livre des juges,
je crois euh dans la l'Ancien Testament
que le temple de Jérusalem se
reconstruit quand on sacrifierait des
génis rousses. Et bien, ils ont fait une
collecte d'argent pour frêter un avion
qui a amené des génis ruses à Jérusalem.
C'est sourcé ça
quoi ?
C'est sourcé.
Je crois que oui.
Non, je crois ça me va pas. C'est toi
qui m'a expliqué que la croyance
institut ça pas tu pens je sais pas.
Ouais. Ouais. Fais pas de blague ici si
c'est pas sourcé.
C'est vérifié. Tuas vérifié.
Ouais. Merci.
Attention Jean-Pierre, je vais me
fâcher. Question internet. Euh quel
crédit donne-il à l'échelle de Kardachf
?
Je sais pas ce que c'est que Cardf.
C'est Je sais pas.
Tu veux que je te l'pelle ? Kilou Alpha
Roméo Delta Alpha Sira hôtel Victens
prennent le conscience de leur modestie
dans le cosmos et de leur banalité. On
est entouré peut-être par une centaine
de planètes habitées de avec des
civilisations. C'est quand même
extraordinaire un truc pareil.
Ton histoire avec les génistes, ça a
l'air d'être sourcé. Merde !
on est pas dans la merde.
Écoute Jean-Pierre, on arrive à la fin
de notre interview. Ouis.
Je voudrais tu veux parler d'un autre
truc avant que tu tu clamses ou pas ?
Quoi ?
Tu veux parler d'un autre truc avant que
tu clamses ou pas ? [rires]
Bah simplement,
tu vas nous manquer, tu sais.
Jean-Pierre,
je me demande à qui à qui on peut
parler. Je me demande actuellement si
les interlocuteurs ça pourrait pas être
des religieux. Il y a peut-être des gens
dans les différentes mouvances, que ce
soit les musulmans ou les chrétiens ou
les juifs qui ont une une élévation
spirituelle suffisante pour entendre des
choses, c'est tout.
Ils en entendent tous les jours, hein.
Quoi ?
Ils en entendent tous les jours.
Oui, mais
je crois que des gens comme ça peuvent
arriver à niveau de de pensée tels qui
sont capables même de remettre en
question leur propres croyance. Moi je
ne dis pas vos croyances c'est du pipot.
Je dis vous vous croyez à des choses et
ces croyances ont secrété cet être
auquel vous croyez.
Moi je vais te poser une question plus
personnelle.
Quand tu as vu les missiles russes
hypersoniques se balader, quand tu as
entendu parler des torpilles à
hypercavitation à la fois russes et
américaines.
Tu as pas pris ton téléphone et tu as
pas appris le tu as pas appelé le
ministère des armées.
Pour quoi ? Attends. En leur
disant "Vous n'êtes qu'une bande de
con." Tu as pas tu as pas eu envie de
faire ça ?
Non non, je perdu. C'est du temps perdu.
Non, moi je pense qu'on a on a un drame
humain actuellement. Moi j'avoue que les
t [rires] tous ces gens qui meurent, moi
j'avoue que je ressens dans mes tripes
tous les jours tous ces jeunes des deux
côtés qui meurent en Ukraine
inutilement. Je trouve ce qui est
monstrueux, c'est des gens qui font des
guerres.
les États-Unis,
les gens commencent à à envisager que
les États-Unis vivent des guerres. Quand
on regarde, ils n'ont pas arrêté de
déclencher des guerres depuis 1945. Ils
ont perdu le Vietnam, ils ont perdu
l'Afghanistan, ils n'arrêtent pas. Et là
maintenant, c'est merveilleux, les
États-Unis ont lancé une opération de
guerre en Iran et quand on demande
pourquoi il a fait ça, je sais pas.
C'est extraordinaire, hein. Voilà. Si il
l'a dit, il a dit le programme
nucléaire, les missiles balistiques.
Mais des gens te diront le fait que les
les les
Iraniens soient à deux doigts d'avoir la
bombe, mais on l'a entendu 10 fois
depuis 20 ans.
Si tu écoutes Israël, c'est urgent. Il
faut imitir.
Les Iraniens, ils t'ont proposé de
travailler avec toi sur leur missile
hypersonique ou pas du tout ?
Les Iraniens, ils t'ont pas proposé de
bosser avec eux ? Mais je passerai
là-dessus avec personne, c'est tout.
C'est même pas la peine de me proposer.
Mais j'ai encore des propositions
française de gens qui sont en train de
monter des des unités de recherche
importantes avec de l'argent. Il se
rendent pas compte. Je dis mais pourquoi
vous me posez la question ? Ma réponse
est non. C'est incroyable.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Alors
attention, je te vois venir gros comme
une maison. trois livres différents de
TBD et ensuite trois TBD.
Moi
je dirais chronique martienne de
Bradbury, hein. Ensuite euh Fahrenheit
du même hauteur.
Voilà.
Et le 3è
et je sais pas quel est le 3è mais
voilà, c'est plutôt une chose comme ça.
Voilà. Un bouquin un bouquin qui a été
important pour toi.
Bah chronique martienne très très
important je pense. Ouais.
Alors maintenant tu peux parler de tes
BD. Tiens montre ça à la télé.
Bien. Alors [raclement de gorge] nous
avons deux deux bouquins. Alors le
premier c'est
modèle génus contre sciences noire.
Et là, à ce moment-là, il y a une
présentation assez exhaustive de tout ça
avec le langage de la bande dessinée.
Voilà. Bon, ça c'est une chose. Puis le
deuxième,
attends, tu as le droit de tourner les
pages, hein.
Quoi ?
Tu as le droit de tourner les pages si
tu es pas à la télé tourner les pages.
Et je voudrais que tu m'en lises. Tu me
lises une bulle.
Ouais.
[grognement]
Là, je vais montrer par exemple un
dessin,
un personnage qu'on reconnaît.
Fais gaffe, le fauteuil est traître.
Voilà, c'est justement quand on a la
première image d'une galaxie entièrement
formée et qui a seulement 500 millions
d'années quoi, au lieu d'un milliard
d'années. Voilà hein. Enfin bon,
regardez la BD.
Al, c'est la seule BD au monde où vous
allez trouver des équations.
H
alors il y a là il y a une image qui
évoque mes rencontres avec Grotend.
Alors, c'est ça qui est étonnant, c'est
que j'ai fréquenté Alexandre Grotendck
qui était un homme qui avait
complètement fui la communauté
scientifique du monde entier et
française. Alors à ce moment-là, la
question c'est comment avez-vous fait
pour entrer en contact ? Mais c'est lui
qui est entré en contact. On avait les
mêmes idées. Quelque m'avait dit "Moi,
je préférais être fusillé plutôt que de
porter un uniforme." Et moi, je veux
dire, je préféris me trancher la gorge
plutôt que de travailler dans
l'armement, c'est tout. C'est pareil. il
le savait très bien. Donc il habitait à
Mormoiron qui est un petit village près
d'Exemp. Il il avait une petite ferme.
Donc c'est là qu'on se rencontrait.
Simplement, il m'avait promis de ne
jamais révéler son secret. Donc je l'ai
fréquenté comme ça pendant des années
sans révéler où il était. Et après quand
il a été [grognement] localisé, il a
foutu le corps dans les Pyrénées quoi.
Mais moi je l'ai connu du temps où il
était à Montmiron. Voilà. Et euh c'est
Grotendic qui m'a poussé à faire les
équations de champ. Disons que le disco
de Grotendic, c'est euh on n'est jamais
assez hard, il faut oser. Euh si cette
cosmologie ne marche pas, c'est qu'il
faut faire mieux qu'Instein. Voilà. Moi,
je disais à C faire mieux que Mais oui,
démerde-toi. Voilà.
Jean-Pierre, est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations ?
Oh oui, c'est
Attends, attends, tu as montré l'autre.
Alors l'autre l'autre c'est le
métaphysicon. C'est le plus important
hein. Le plus important. Voilà. Alors
est-ce qu'on peut montrer des images à
l'intérieur comme chez toi ?
Euh il y a il y a beaucoup de choses
là-dedans, hein.
Bon, on on retrouve l'évocation de
Grotic ici. Vous l'avez voilà ici. Mais
bon, voilà. Sourot que j'ai représenté
en alchimiste. Voyez ici avec son Ah ben
Souri c'est tout à fait ça. C'est
extraordinaire. un personnage
complètement ou en couleur. Voilà. Alors
simplement quand on fait une émission
comme celle-là, il faut toujours avoir
une phrase à la fin comme un conseil
donné aux jeunes génération. Mais je
dirais ça se résume en une seule phrase.
Ne prenez pas tout ce que vous entendez
pour argent content. Voilà et ça ça mène
très loin.
Jean-Pierre Petit, merci.
[musique]